Alex Jones in his latest defamation
trial has been ordered to pay nearly one
billion dollars 965 million to the
families in the Sandy Hook uh
uh the circumstance and uh I'm I'm
shocked I'm outraged a billion dollars
that's it it should be a gajillion but
magillion trillion because let's be real
a billion dollars is a meaningless
number not only does Alex Jones not have
it but it's a ridiculous number to award
someone anyway and it just shows it's
just it's just all nonsense now Alex
Jones come out saying he's not going
anywhere he's not gonna stop and you
can't you can't sue someone into not
existing so there's there's work arounds
and I I'm I'd be really surprised if any
of these people actually see a penny
from Alex Jones he's claiming he doesn't
have it he's claiming it's broke we will
see how that plays out in the next story
man
this is brutal John fetterman he's
running for office he did an interview
with NBC and he was unable to understand
the questions asked of him the
journalist who did the interview said
that during Small Talk he couldn't
understand what she was saying he can
hear the words but his brain can't
process it he needed a special device
that transcribes what people are saying
into text so that he can answer these
questions and I just think right there
it shows the dude is not mentally fit to
be a senator and and you know what I'll
tell you Democrats will still vote for
him because they voted for Joe Biden too
but here's my warning man you look at
what happened when you vote for someone
like Joe Biden because you don't care
that he's clearly not with it you're
like well whatever we'll let him win now
look at your economy and I'll get your
gas prices look at the war even Biden's
saying we're close to Armageddon not
okay we're going to talk about all this
but before we do head over to eat right
and feelwell.com to pick up your key to
no Elevate MCT C8 oil powder that's
medium chain triglyceride oil powder
many of you pointed out that in a new
interview it's an old interview actually
that was released of me I was looking
quite round well in fact I cut out the
sugars started eating some of this keto
Elevate powder putting in my coffee and
uh it was really fast actually the
weight just like melted off as soon as I
got rid of the sugars the greasy stuff
and just started doing keto that's what
that that's what really helps so go to
eat rightandfeelwell.com and you will
get 51 off as well as a 60-day
money-back guarantee keto Elevate
provides your body only C8 the most
ketogenic MCT that means it provides
support for energy levels healthy
appetite Management Mental Clarity and
focus athletic performance here to
elevate personally it's my favorites on
the market I mentioned this every so
often we had someone actually brought
some other stuff over and I didn't like
it I really do like the stuff it's great
in coffee
you get free shipping on every order and
for every order every order today
BioTrust will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kidhungry.org
to date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year you'll get free VIP live
health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order and uh
maybe we can do it we'll do like a side
by side we'll pull up a picture of me
from like two years ago and the next
time we do this because you can see like
I actually I lost like 30 some odd
pounds so people were pointing it out
but yeah man keto works at least I can
say that you talk to your doctor or go
talk to the experts over at BioTrust
EatRight and feelwell.com and don't
forget to head over to timcast.com
become a member and support our work
directly we got a new show coming soon
with Shane Cashman he's going to be
talking live super chats thunderstorms
Mysteries paranormal UFOs Bigfoot I'm
super excited for this show it'll
probably be the only show I actually
listen to because usually I'm just
reading the news but as a member you're
also supporting our journalists and
you'll get access to the uncensored Tim
cast IRL show Monday through Thursday at
11 PM we will have one of those episodes
coming up for you tonight so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this show with your friends be the
notification people are saying they're
not getting notifications anymore we
need you to be the notification so that
people can actually find out the show
exists and it's on because uh well we're
probably being censored joining us today
to talk about all of this and more is
Andrew gold hello thanks for having me
on what a pleasure to be here oh thanks
for coming who are you I am a British as
you can hear journalist and uh
documentary maker and podcaster host of
the on the edge with Andrew gold uh
podcast I look into all sorts of Cults
and ideologies I think the most
controversial aspects uh thereof is uh
that I consider woke ideology and that
kind of thing as one of the ideologies
and uh adult yeah I think so that's why
you're here because we say it all the
time I think so that is called ish at
least it's cold it's a weird kind of
like
decentralized cult yeah I guess yeah
that centers on the Internet or
something it's got some comparisons to
former ones you know like Bolsheviks and
things like that uh the the Puritans
back in the well I don't even know when
that was when was that the 18th century
Puritans the Bolshevik one is the scary
one considering what's going on
politically yeah it comes from this it
comes from like all cults and and
religions and things that all comes from
this uh need to be righteous to to feel
like you're better than someone to to
raise your status uh your virtue higher
than other people as you raise your
microphone as well as I raise my mind
richness yeah and and it's just you know
the rest of us see through it but they
continue this crazy crazy charades we
got we got we got a lot to talk about in
that regard too
um also Elon Musk sold burnt hair
cologne or something whatever Luke's
here well uh Cheerio bloke nice to have
you here over the pond my name is we are
change.org the FDA just announced
another emergency use authorization for
small children today so I decided to be
very brave and support this action by
wearing my 1984 doses to slow the spread
now we're still a little behind but I
think we're going to get there
eventually and uh if if you agree you
could get the shirt on the best
politicalshirts.com because you do I'm
here thank you so much for having me
Luke uh one of my concerns that my my
son was dinging a little bit too much
into the microphone if you've heard the
ding ding ding ding so I got a nice
large wooden one in the meantime thanks
Luke and if you didn't catch it today I
did an interview with the one the only
hotep Jesus Brian Sharp on his YouTube
channel if you haven't seen yet you're
going to want to check it out after this
show maybe you can catch it before the
after after show which will be up at 11
o'clock P.M on timcast.com
what's going on search hey guys I'm here
again you can't get rid of me that
easily
um I am here elydia is not here if you
haven't heard the news a lot of people
haven't heard the news at all apparently
they'll figure out eventually she's on
the monastery we wish her luck yeah we
do and uh I guess that's it we'll start
search is here pressing the buttons from
uh henceforth let's jump into this first
story from the AP uh it's just so silly
Alex Jones ordered to pay 965 million
dollars for Sandy Hook lies an hour ago
I I saw that and I just burst it out
laughing I think I was on the toilet and
I'm like I'm looking at my phone and I'm
like like writing the news breaks I was
like is this a joke come on it you know
when they did the 50 million dollars I
was like wow that's brutal they're still
I still doubt anyone's gonna get a penny
from this because the way lawsuits work
Alex Jones says he doesn't even have the
money anyway then they they're a billion
this is this is just like what is this
for narrative and for the TV to say oh
you know he lied about this and now he's
got to pay one billion dollars is it
reminds me of Austin Powers when uh in
the first one he freezes himself and
then he goes to the Future and he says I
want one million dollars and they all
laugh at him and then they're like Dr
Evil one million dollars today isn't
actually a lot of money and he's like oh
and then in the next one he goes back in
time and says I want a hundred billion
dollars and I'll start laughing at him
again saying you might as well have just
said a bajillion gajillion dollars that
money doesn't exist this is what it is
like who and and who in their right mind
thinks Alex Jones has a billion dollars
to give away I don't think anyone I
don't and I mean I mean he's been pretty
transparent with his finances and he
doesn't I don't understand there's a
phrase squeezing trying to squeeze blood
from a stone from a turnip from a turn
up yeah uh I I don't know how the law
Works in this kind of situation where
someone gets sued for money that they
don't have I'm sorry I'm sorry this is
the biggest judgment in U.S history
apparently for defamation and it's
people want a judgment for defamation
that weren't even named by Alex Jones I
don't understand this there were like
six people six people families and an
FBI agent that was involved somehow is
pain and suffering from something else I
mean I understand he named someone and
then that person has phone calls people
went to that person's house I think I
don't know what the extent of the what
happened that I get that guy can sue for
defamation he got named for something
that but the rest of them I don't I
don't understand this and it's setting a
precedent there wasn't even a trial they
just had a judgment because they had
problems with Discovery and uh this is
the second of a of three trials they're
still going to be yet another trial and
this settlement you know this this
judgment excuse me is almost as big as
of course one of the biggest Health Care
fraud settlements in history which was
given to Pfizer that had to pay 2.3
billion dollars for fraudulent marketing
back a couple years ago so uh when you
compare the two uh you know bad opinions
compared to what Pfizer did back then
there's a big difference well here's a
question then so so what should what
should happen I don't have nonsense
let's say you're a parent of the Sandy
Hook thing uh you're devastated and
they're people turning up your house
because of what Alex Jones said what
should happen maybe nothing well I mean
that's tough uh for one Alex had said
that under Texas law you have to say
someone's name for it to be defamation
and that he was just saying these people
and those people but I think he did name
one person there was one individual he
named uh I'll say this Alex Jones went
on a show to a massive audience and said
things that were not true he's allowed
to have his opinions but when he said
things definitively there's a question
there of defamation when you when you
call out someone with false information
it was not a public figure I don't think
the New York Times should be allowed to
get away with it my big issue my there's
there's a couple of things I I have is
here one a billion dollars is just the
stupidest thing I've ever heard
uh they didn't give him a trial and when
it when are any of these big major media
organizations ever going to be held to
account in any in any in any way let
alone anyway like this it's not
happening so you can see how the machine
comes for people who are outside of the
establishment I would say I would find
it reasonable if Alex Jones was actually
ordered to pay you know six figures to
each family for each family member
something like that maybe the total
payout would have been like five million
bucks and they would have said that to
cover the cost of security and moving
all the legitimate you know um
all the legitimate costs incurred by
these families but the idea is here
punitive damages the the judges act I'm
sorry the lawyers actually said to the
jury find him so much he cannot
keep his business up or up and running
or something something to that effect so
the goal here is to punish him so that
he doesn't do it again and I just think
that is where I say no that's wrong and
I'll tell you Alex Jones is allowed to
be wrong about things he's allowed to
have his opinion about things now if he
defamed by saying statements of facts
that were not true about private
individuals then I think he owes them
damages but if it was that he truly
believed it and he was expressing his
opinion in a major news event then I
don't see how you come after him for
tens of millions or even a billion
dollars paying for actual damages
because you you were wrong and spread
misinformation about someone that
damaged their life that I understand
I'm thinking about a metaphor I know
you'll love it uh about like social
media Administration and one of the
things that Minds that we talk about is
so if you ban someone for violating
terms of service you ban the channel and
then when they try and make a new
channel some of the admins would be like
no they can't make any more channels
they violated the terms I'm like no no
you're not Banning the person you're
Banning the channel the channel violated
the terms so it's the same thing with
Alex you you you you don't stop him from
coming back that's not the point you
punish him for the for the fraud or
whatever or the the problem but there's
no like preventing people from existing
or a realm back to you know normality I
that's my opinion anyway or Redemption
you know it's essential right the human
the conversation is about Redemption
we're all I mean that's the Christian
ethos these people aren't Christians
well our society should is kind of based
on it and and that's I think that's a
good thing
um I think uh progress is a good thing
but I think there's there's a lot of
values that come from
uh
Christian values that I think are good
notably like innocent until proven
guilty is a really good one there's a
lot of bad ones and and we found over
the over a long period of time we've
gotten rid of the bad ones but I think
with with this the issue comes down to
you cannot get rid of Alex Jones it's
impossible okay here you go
um John Smith starts a media company and
then says Alex I'm gonna hire you and
I'm going to pay you ten dollars an hour
to host you know this show a benefit of
working for this company is that you're
going to eat at a five-star restaurant
steakhouse every night the company pays
for your Penthouse and you get a car a
corporate car and you get corporate
private jets but you only get paid 10
bucks an hour what are they gonna do
Brad that's cool what are they gonna do
so if Alex Jones has a personality on a
show generates millions of dollars tens
of millions hundreds of millions so if
they sue him into Oblivion he has a
trusted individual who sets a company
and hires them and then what now if at
that point he says something again they
can sue that company sure but then what
just do it again it's it's ridiculous
you cannot there's nothing you can do to
stop Alex Jones He is Unstoppable he is
he is a gigantic man Boulder rolling
down a hill you will not stop him
screaming on the top of his life going
crazy
I want you to imagine Alex Jones rolling
down a hill at 100 miles an hour just he
hits the bottom of that ramp and then he
just goes flying into the air and then
Supernova yeah and he's like meditating
in the sky as he's flying like that
Pokemon not Pikachu I forgot who it is
but but let me let me say this how many
times I'll put it this way the New York
Times the lies about the Iraq War and
all of that stuff that the the lies
about Iraq that got us into a war that
cost what how many people died yeah
really how many how many innocent
civilians were killed how much money was
wasted how much damage just around the
world because of this
have we sued the New York Times into
Oblivion to make sure they can never
operate again
no of course not they just say well you
know don't do it again
and we all suffer because of it Alex
Jones says incorrect things about a
bunch of families that I I think he was
it was wrong of him to say and in the
end they're like let's make sure he can
never ever run a company they want to
destroy not just his life they want to
destroy the lives of anyone who worked
for him even a guy who's like a
groundskeeper or a security guard that's
insane I want to tell you one more very
very important thing especially as it
pertains to censorship
when they censored Alex Jones on YouTube
this isn't very important they did not
just take away his ability to speak they
deleted the entire Archive of all of the
work he had ever produced and published
on that platform that's the scary thing
about social media censorship it doesn't
just say you can't talk anymore Twitter
Facebook YouTube erases your entire
history gone and then you can't comply
with Discovery and then they're like
where's the video clips where's the
video footage where's your apology when
when did you say sorry show us the
details and of course no one has the
ability to have that many hard drives
that that many backups of how I mean he
streams essentially what is it four
hours a day on his show and then there's
a bunch of other shows that he goes on
so it's just impossible and truly the
larger censorship efforts are repundant
and disgusting and the corporate media
does what Alex Jones does every single
day the only difference is they never
get held accountable for all the lies
and all the disinformation that they
spew repundant yeah that's a that's a
word right repugnant I love that potato
potato you know what I'm saying I
thought it was a word I didn't know but
there you go yeah it sounded quite good
to me but the context transfer people
got people got it is the issue is the
issue that I mean this was an emotional
reaction I suppose it's like a billion
dollars or whatever it is I I do agree
with what you're saying uh actually now
that I think about this to delete
someone's entire Archive of work seems
insane but I also just feel like what is
to stop all of us now from just saying
whatever we want that completely ruins
someone's life that might not be true
what should be human decency I guess uh
morals ethics
um to it to an extent the Christian
values that uh were instilled in this
country whether you like them or don't
they're there
uh what should be done is defamation
towards civil tort you you know I think
we have a problem with times V Sullivan
are you familiar with times V Sullivan
this is a precedent that basically says
politicians and public Figures it's not
just times of Sullivan there's another
court case that added to it but it's
about it's basically the precedent that
says
if you're a public figure then there's a
higher degree of scrutiny and I think
that you know there's good things and
bad things about it but I think it kind
of weighs on on the negative what this
means is
if CNN comes out and lies about me and
says that you know Tim Poole you know
punched a dog
and then I sue and say no I didn't
they'll say you're a public figure
oh well that's no good no and so I mean
saying that I punched a dog is a very
definitive thing it's so they they
probably would have a hard time with
saying something that definitive but
they can come out and say that you're a
known white supremacist who sympathizes
and and does this that or otherwise and
then if you try and Sue they'll say it's
a protected opinion against a public uh
you know public uh person and so it you
case dismissed if you're a private
individual then you've got way more
grounds which is why Alex Jones
basically lost here but I think the real
reason he lost here is because the
machine was out to get him that's my
opinion on the matter I mean it's pretty
clear I mean look what the corporate
media does just a few months ago uh
during the whole Afghanistan debacle the
United States Pentagon military
literally launched a missile strike and
killed a native worker the U.S corporate
media said that he was Isis K that he
was a terrorist he was an aid worker
that was bringing fresh water to
Afghanistan that's liable that's
defamation this family is being defamed
as some kind of new radical islamist
Terror wrists when in reality they were
working with the US government bringing
fresh water to Afghanistan is the
corporate media going to be held
responsible for that particular incident
of defamation of lying about someone
that just had their entire family
annihilated in a in a drone strike that
the corporate media and the U.S pentagon
were lying about no should they if we're
going to be playing by these rules
absolutely and I think you would get a
reward more than a billion dollars for
such defamations and such actions if
we're playing by the same rules set by
the president of this particular court
uh hearing I don't normally do super
chats this early but there is one that I
want to address because I brought it up
and I think for people who are listening
to the segment they should hear it
Augusto mimichay says where is innocent
until proven guilty in the Bible he who
is without sin isn't the same no it is
the story of Sodom and Gomorrah and it
was I think it was Abraham was talking
to God and God was like you know I'm
probably getting the story wrong with
the general ideas you know I'm gonna
blow up these cities because they're
full of you know nasty people and then
he he asks but what if there are 50
right righteous people and he's like
okay if there are 50 righteous people I
won't blow it up I said what about 40.
okay if there's 40 and then finally
comes down to what if there's but one
righteous man and he says okay if
there's one righteous man I will not
destroy these cities the idea there is
that you cannot condemn someone to death
if they are a righteous person right
that's a general idea that was the
inspiration for blackstone's formulation
it is better that 10 guilty persons
Escape than one innocent person suffer
which then went to Benjamin Franklin who
said is better than a hundred guilty
persons Escape than one innocent person
suffer and the philosophy there the
legal and moral and governmental
philosophy is if people don't have faith
that has innocent individuals they will
be protected from false accusations if
people believe that even if they are
innocent the machine will try to crush
them then they don't lend their
confidence to government government
doesn't work ultimately this becomes the
element of the government that is you
must have a trial you must be proven
guilty you can confront your accusers
and you are innocent until they prove
you're guilty it's amazing I I was
reading about you know why I was reading
about the Constitution where these ideas
came from why we had them and I traced
that one all the way back it was very
very fascinating so uh yeah there we go
they say they say that 10 of people in
prison are innocent and it reminds me of
Amanda Knox remember Amanda oh yeah yeah
she was on my my podcast and she's this
lovely person she seems so nice and the
minute I put that out the amount of
abuse I got and that she got she now has
to live with that because people don't
go by innocent until proven guilty
they're just all convinced she did it
you know
you know yeah yeah and that's the
problem with stuff like uh this Alex
Jones thing most people uh don't even
know the full details of the of the
trial and I'm not going to pretend to
either I think if you if you watch
someone like Viva fry you might get a
much much better understanding of how
the court case played out and everything
like that but then you take a look at
like the Ahmed Aubry case you take a
look at the Kyle Rittenhouse case there
are Mobs with pitchforks going around
demanding violent ends to to you know to
and and they don't even know what
happened like hands up don't shoot
people were riding over the Michael
Brown stuff they turned out to be fake
Ferguson was the West Florissant in
Ferguson was burnt to the ground all
these buildings over lies lies from the
media and the media went there and they
were all gloating and talking about I
was a great networking event these
people are nasty people man
so I don't think this is uh this is
going to be a devastating blow against
Alex Jones because he is very persistent
and I think he's definitely going to
figure out a lot of different ways
around this I think he already has
safeguarded a lot of his assets and a
lot of his uh a lot of his businesses
but but also more importantly a lot of
legal experts are saying that he's going
to win on appeal when it comes to of
course challenging this major decision
there are still again one more court
hearing that's going to of course be
going after him but more importantly I
think with hyperinflation the one
billion dollars is going to be a
cakewalk especially with the value of
the dollar going down with the Federal
Reserve Quantic quantitative easing
policies that have utterly destroyed our
currency and a billion dollars is going
to be nothing in a few in a few months
from now let's jump to this next one
this is from Candace Owens who tweeted
earlier today I learned that Kanye West
was officially kicked out of JP Morgan
Chase Bank I was told there was no
official official reason given but they
sent this letter as a as well to confirm
that he has until late November to find
another place for the Yeezy Empire 2
Bank this is nuts here the letter says
Dear ye is that his real name yeah he
had it officially changed you now wow
all right there you go we're sending
this letter to confirm our recent
discussion with blank JP Morgan Bank
will has decided to end its banking
relationship with Yeezy LLC et cetera et
cetera the first thing I'm going to say
before we get into the political
ramifications of this is make sure you
are using parallel economy I know it's a
relatively new uh Financial Service
co-founded by Dan bongino shout out to
Dan who's doing tremendous work to help
fight back against censorship if you
become a member at timcast.com we
default parallel economy support
businesses that are fighting back that
believe in these values parallel economy
is one of them Kanye West I will say it
right now Candace Owens Kanye West
talk to parallel economy they're not a
bank they do financial transaction
services but talk to them because if
Kanye said okay I won't use I won't use
uh Chase I'll use this bank and I'll use
this financial service it can be a major
movement towards pushing back against
censorship and Kanye is big enough to
make a huge impact on that regard in
that regard so here we go ladies and
gentlemen uh you will owe nothing and
you will be happy
you want to take this one or should I be
the federal you don't own your money
anyway people think that's their money
that's what Federal Reserve notes on
loan they can take them back if they
want they can shut you down doesn't it
even say on like money or something
something about this Federal Reserve
Note it's a promissory note that they
give it to the American government the
American government promises to pay them
back a dollar plus interest for every
dollar they bought such so uh ethereum
right Luke no no the other guy was
Shilling for it uh but that's another
topic to discuss here uh again
decentralized currencies are another
thing but but the Federal Reserve is
building their own centralized digital
currency which is going to lead to
behavioral like this tenfold and this is
not the first time that a major banking
institution punished someone because of
their opinions uh I I think that's
what's Happening Here we don't know
exactly what's happening here maybe
there's some accusations by Chase
Manhattan that they didn't want to of
course make public but it's most likely
what's been happening previously before
and that's we don't like your opinion
we're going to make sure you can't exist
in society we're going to make sure or
that you as an individual can't have any
free flow of transactions which is
absolutely crazy can I just give a shout
out real quick to uh Candace Owens
profile picture on Twitter it's the
Communist Fest appropriated by BLM
holding lots of cash and it's melting
that's funny yeah you don't like
ethereum I I question everything and I'm
skeptical of everything so
um again when it comes to you know a lot
of these digital currencies I think
skepticism is your best friend uh I
always feels clearly better than Bitcoin
Luke I told people Mark Zuckerberg is
your friend yeah I told people from the
very beginning invest what you're
willing to lose because it's a wild West
Market I do believe there are tremendous
opportunities for decentralization
especially when it comes to privacy
coins uh things like Monero there's a
reason the IRS is sending out messages
and letters saying please help us crack
Monero there's a reason Amazon and Jeff
Bezos are building uh technology that
will break of course encryption so so I
I do believe in privacy coins but I
don't believe in what the world economic
forum and a lot of the other big Bankers
are pushing and that centralized digital
currencies uh the CEO of BlackRock was
just talking about how how the situation
in Ukraine is going to lead to a bigger
push for centralized digital currencies
that's essentially what they're pushing
for a social credit score where they
will track trace and database and punish
you on the Fly for wrong think just like
they probably did to Kanye West with
Chase Manhattan Bank I'm pretty
flabbergasted I didn't know that Banks
and PayPal of course at the moment I
didn't know they could actually do this
based on your views they can just say
okay well we're going to take your money
or you can't use us for your money I had
no idea that was allowed they can't do
that in the UK well I think they can but
I didn't know yeah I didn't know I'd
imagine it's probably worse in the UK
yeah quite possibly the PayPal stuff
started happening to quite a few people
I know in in the UK I started seeing it
happening on Twitter loads people saying
well my PayPal is closed no one's told
me why don't know what's going on I mean
I've been stressed out about the whole
free speech thing for quite some time
now just the way people are clamping
down on it using culture and oppressed
to stop people just having views look
the Kanye Westing I'm Jewish I've grown
up Jewish my family's Jewish friends are
Jewish I was you know properly actually
Jewish it's very offensive what he said
I take it with a pinch of salt because
he's Kanye West you know he says mad
things all the time and whatever you
hear it every day anyway so okay
whatever but I I don't I wouldn't want
to have a bank that doesn't allow people
who disagree with me or say horrible
things to me to be able to keep their
money there and it's the same with
speech I want people who've got opposite
opinions to mine to be able to say
whatever they want and and people can
decide if they want to listen to them
you know
would you have debanked Hitler if you
were running the bank that he was using
when he uh declared war on Poland I
think once he's once you've started the
war it might be a bit different if
you're trying to stop but but I don't
know that's over my pay grade what would
you have done he was getting financed by
the bushes and and the the Rockefeller
Prescott Bush didn't use my bank as a
weapon to win the war I mean I'll be
honest that's what this is I mean we say
it's a culture War we kind of joke and
laugh it's a real culture War sure like
it's it's a domination for your mind
sure but that's different that's you
trying to win a win a war we're not
trying to win a war against Kanye West
but sanctions and War happen all the
time tons of people say we're no longer
going to do business with you and your
your money's Frozen this is a private
citizen United States being told that
he's being kicked off of a bank now we
don't know exactly why they didn't say
why but we know why yeah he's in the
news they're saying he's offensive I
think this is actually really really bad
for Chase and they made a big mistake
because we saw what happened with PayPal
their stock is down I think I don't know
where it's at right now let me let me
let me check PayPal stock for the day
because it was up early let's see where
it's at so it's up 0.87 but in the past
five days they're down 10 percent so
since this news broke over the weekend
there's they're down 10 dude while
you're here look at their last five
years look at what happened April 2020
to PayPal stock covet has announced
guess out all these people made three
times the money and then sold it all and
then they went back to normal someone
tripled their money lots of yeah but
that means someone lost their money I
imagine it was Pension funds I think a
cabal of organizations tripled their
money by investing in PayPal through the
pandemic and then got out and then a
bunch of people that were trying to ride
the wave probably bought in while it was
up yeah people knew commerce was going
to of course happen online and not in
person and not in real life so it was an
investment that a lot of people
predicted oh I I've heard stories from
people who bought moderna stock who
someone told me this they bought moderna
stock route at the start of the pandemic
because they were like oh the media is
talking about it and then what was that
like a 100 times increase or like a 40
times increase on your money invest
thing in these machines and then getting
rich off them like investing in PayPal
knowing that people have to buy online
and they can't use you know Mom and Pop
sure stores and Bodega so there was
money to be made I don't I don't think
it's necessarily necessarily the what
you think it is Ian it's probable that a
lot of powerful Elites were playing
games I think a lot of it was people
being like I'm gonna invest in in PayPal
and Amazon and Netflix and all of their
stocks skyrocketed because people
couldn't leave their houses
so maybe maybe it wasn't Paul Pelosi is
that yeah Nancy's husband Nancy husband
Paul Paul Pelosi Greg Trader smart guy
very smart you know Wall Street it's
almost like he's like psychic like he
just knows these things are gonna happen
or like he has like a like his wife like
has some inside scoop or something yeah
it's almost like his wife is the speaker
of the house and has an inside track on
what builds it's probably more likely
that he site it's almost as his wife is
making all the decisions in Big Industry
that of course is directly correlated to
some of the big trades that he's making
welcome to the modern era my friends
they went after Kanye West man I guess
that's what that's what happens well we
still don't know exactly what happened
here I we we could speculate it's
probably because of his more spicy
controversial cut you know topics and
and conversations I've been seeing like
a little scuttlebutt of what he's been
saying uh but but you know again when
Banks get more involved when when
there's more social pressure you know
this is creating a society that that is
essentially a social credit score you
can't think the wrong things you can't
express the wrong things and even if you
do Express the wrong ideas at least have
the ability to be able to of course have
them challenged have them question
because that's how you stop someone from
uh believing in bad things you question
those things and you actually talk them
through it instead of just censoring
them which actually pushes them to the
further extremes and has them go to
places where they get more radicalized
and they get more crazy belief systems
which again is psychologically proven to
be true I think that you're right that
diplomacy and communication is the way
is kind of the United States was based
on a bunch of people that didn't agree
got together and then they started
figuring it out together and they didn't
have Global Wars but the problem now is
that we don't I don't speak Russian I
don't speak China I don't speak Mandarin
and so to debate and have conversation
globally in this new it'd be like if
people in West Virginia spoke Mandarin
but people in Massachusetts spoke Uh
Russian and but were still expected for
those people to somehow work together it
wouldn't have happened they had a Common
Language and now in the globe we don't
have a common language we kind of have
English but I don't understand the
Russian guys speak in Russian
um and that's I don't understand what
Kanye West is saying have the time to
pick up Juliana yeah oh yeah we listened
to one of his shows like it was like I
do not understand I was like I get every
word man he's just a wild uh frequency
yeah no he's talking to Carlson his
Tucker Carlson interview was was very
coherent it was it was very good yeah we
we we listened to that I thought it was
like one there yeah and then their Vice
came out and was like listen to what
Kanye really said but Tucker edited it
out and I was like it's just that's like
one controversial thing he he's a Black
Hebrew Israelite I guess Kanye West
believes that he's a true Jew and I'm
like I don't know I I maybe took across
and took it out because it didn't flow
the conversation and it's like they cut
it for time yeah oh because uh Judaism
has passed through blood that's the idea
and so he says his great ancestors were
Jewish no no no Black Hebrew Israelites
believe that black people are the true
you know Children of the Israel or
whatever and that uh the people there
currently are like occupying it and
stole it from them or something
interesting when when BLM first started
getting really big a year or two ago
that was quite a difficult time for a
lot of Jewish people because a lot of
anti-Semitism came from there and then
there was a lot of sort of Jewish black
rivalry stuff going on for about a year
or so so I I lived in um Crown Heights
in Brooklyn and there was a huge Jewish
like there were shootouts between Jewish
acidic Jewish people and and the black
community like it was weird yeah and uh
they just had like a mobile command at
like this dividing line between the two
neighborhoods and I just I didn't I
didn't really understand it but then I
uh several years later when I started I
was covering a riot in Baltimore and
these kids were talking about there is
they were they were Muslim and they
started talking about a lot of this
stuff and they're they're just like
coming up with the cameras and then
yelling stuff and then people started
explaining to me like Farrakhan and all
the stuff I wasn't super familiar with
and I was like ah okay I get it right so
you've got these people who believe
really really anti-semitic things we saw
we saw the reporting from I think it was
I think it was the New York Times and
tablet about the heads of BLM were
extremely anti-semitic spreading these
conspiracy theories about Jewish people
and all that stuff so well this was this
was a really weird time because it's so
because BLM was everywhere in the UK the
UK I mean in some senses is further left
in more woke than American in other ways
in other senses is the opposite we tend
to take our lead from you guys
um something happens here and six months
later it's like all over the UK and BLM
of course that happened in the UK and it
almost doesn't make sense the statistics
and everything in the UK it didn't
really make sense I think like three uh
black people over 10 years had been
killed by police or whatever it's a
total we don't have as any black people
in the UK it's totally different thing
but BLM went crazy and then I had to go
to like soccer games right and I would
see just like the t-shirts had BLM all
over them BLM was written everywhere and
I'm just sitting there with my dad and
that and we're just watching it like as
Jewish people we're like where's my
where's my decision in this because I
know that the organization I don't know
I don't have a problem with the words
black lives matter but that organization
the anarchode Marxist uh anti-semitic
thing why do I have to watch that on my
football club now yeah it was it wasn't
nice to have to watch so you talk about
cults and stuff like that we mentioned
earlier in the show that the wokeness is
very much a kind of cult but uh what are
your thoughts on all this in the United
States in the UK just generally in the
west it's it's just a bit what I think
it comes from uh status and or status I
think you guys say right yeah yeah so
status there's a theory and I I I owe a
writer called will store for this about
about status status we sort of evolved
um in tribes and there were three types
of status uh one was dominance one was
success and one was virtue
um so you could either you would get
more of the food if you were
particularly dominant in a tribe you
would get more of the food if you were
successful if you're successful in a
tribe you would start uh you're maybe
good at making the fire you invented the
wheel everybody's gonna share their food
with you now if you're not particularly
dominant as a person if you're not
particularly successful the third option
was state was virtue uh and you had to
show that you're a really nice guy
you're going to share your food with
people you know you're going to help
someone if they need it then they're
going to share their food food with you
but the thing was you didn't actually
have to be virtuous you didn't have to
actually help people you had to make it
appear like you had to Signal your
virtue exactly that exactly that and
they found like uh there have been
studies shown that people who do that a
lot are more likely to be Psychopathic
or narcissistic that makes sense oh yeah
I wonder if uh what we're seeing is
basically there's like this um
Grand restart or something a great reset
that's happening and what what happens
then is people who don't have purpose
become Wayward you know what is it the
Idle Hands the Devil's Playground so you
have a bunch of people who have nothing
to do no Specialties no expertise
they're just listless wandering NPCs or
whatever irrelevant and so in this
hollow hole in their heart they fill it
with fake purpose and so they join the
machine and that's why they're so
adamant about never giving it up no
matter what why is it that we had Larry
Elder here and he says you know I tried
showing the quote the transcription from
Trump where Trump did not say you know
very fine people and stuff he said the
white supremacist should be condemned
totally and they refuse to read it it's
because they have nothing in their
hearts and and and so you know for me
I play music I play Magic the Gathering
I skateboard I rollerblade uh we're
writing songs we we talk politics I am
very full of purpose
but what about someone who has nothing
what about someone who's not really that
good at playing guitar what if someone's
not really good at playing games what if
someone has no hobbies and they have no
friends
the only thing they have is to latch
onto this ideology that's the one thing
they have and then you come along the
nerve of you trying to give them the
truth which would shatter the only thing
they have in their hearts they won't
allow it they go nuts and that's why
they they get violent on behalf of it
it's the only thing they have but their
only passion you're spot on I think
that's exactly it but I think it's the
same reason people sometimes go really
far right it's the same reason people
get into Scientology or Mormonism or
whatever it is often they don't quite
have something in their lives I always
remember you know when I I was a bit uh
I don't think I was woke but maybe liver
when I was like 18 19 years old you go
to university right you know when you go
and everybody's got in their dorms like
posters of the of like this is who I am
I'm someone who likes The Godfather and
it's like well Everyone likes The
Godfather you know but that's my
individuality and and hopefully as you
get older you start to as you say take
up more interests you don't identify it
you know everyone's gotten their Pro you
know pronouns or whatever it might be in
their Twitter profile and you know why
do we need to know what that well I want
to know if you play guitar as you say I
want to know what you do in your life
what's interesting and those are the
people I think sometimes who are LED
into cultish groups they don't have
anything like me you know so uh I like
to skate was uh it was a rollerblading
alert today and every day when I do I'm
trying to one-up myself
so I'm trying to go higher on the vert
ramp or I'm trying to do something I've
never done before and that that's
fulfilling and it's accomplishment I'm
challenging myself every day but for if
you're someone who doesn't have that
then the only thing you have to give you
that dopamine release is going to be
fitting in and having someone else
praise you or feeling like you know
you've latched onto something or eating
yeah eating or eating anything maybe
that's why a lot of them are morbidly
obese no joke
if you feel depression you want
serotonin you eat that's a big thing
that definitely raises your mood well
you know and the food's being engineered
to become addictive but that's another
uh process in itself I remember a couple
years ago looking at psychological
studies specifically when it came to
radical uh jihadists and a lot of
psychologists found that it was poverty
and polyamory that led to of course
people becoming radicalists because
there there wasn't enough women for the
guys to go around one guy would marry 10
to 12 to 15 to 20 wives and there wasn't
enough wives to go around because of the
poverty because of the lack of Education
a lot of people just you know went to
extremist groups so when you look at
those conditions when you look at what's
happening in in today's day and age in
the dating world when you look at what's
happening financially with the banks and
the big multinational corporations
pretty much stealing everyone's money
we're pretty much creating the same
situation for radicalization so uh yes
the things are not going to be good with
so many people radicalized with so many
people going to the fringes and going to
these extremist groups that they're
going to be taken advantage of with and
now we have the Cults becoming prominent
in government in major corporations and
institutions uh
have you have you studied or read up on
other tradition more traditional Cults
stuff like Scientology or Nexium or
those kinds of things sure I don't know
about those specifically those are more
modern but I mean there have been you
know uh it was it Jim Jones is that his
name yeah yeah yeah Jonestown Johnstown
that was mad I I used those because I
think we have well actually uh
Scientology might be a good example as
well but I think Jonestown is it's very
definitive it had an end there's a lot
of that we know about it what what are
are there similarities or can you can
you look at something like that and then
try and predict where we go with the
modern woke cult well Jonestown I think
is is really rare just in terms of how I
mean I use the word cultish to think you
know something is cultist maybe it's one
out of ten cultists and Jonestown was 10
out of 10. Scientology is like a 9 out
of ten or a 10 out of 10 or something uh
Heaven's Gate was the other one do you
remember that one oh yeah was that where
they thought they were going to go on
the the car or whatever yeah yeah
I mean did they drink the Kool-Aid too
yeah so that's actually a misnomer the
Kool-Aid thing I think it wasn't
Kool-Aid it was something else but it
got remembered as Kool-Aid yes I love
how it you know always like this this
story is it's relatively modern as in
the 90s yeah I think so and now drink
the Kool-Aid has become like a slang
term for buying into something and it's
wrong oh it's flavored yeah it was
flavored yeah oh not flavored it was uh
cyanide poison force and if you there's
video audio of them eating it and people
didn't want to they were refusing they
were screaming they were taking babies
away from mothers to poison the baby and
the mothers were screaming I think it's
horrific it's on YouTube are you talking
about Jim Jones now Jones down okay I
don't know about um Heaven's gay so
don't so Jonestown they yeah people
believe that they all killed themselves
and they're like how did that happen and
that's not really what happened they
tried to escape as you say and there
were security guards just shooting them
and killing them all dead dude that's
like a 40 minute video because they're
cultists the guy in charge Jim Jones was
being caught I think the FBI I think it
was it would have been the CIA were in
Guyana sort of checking up on him and he
knew his days were numbered right so it
was like okay this is the next step we
all have to we all have to kill
ourselves now right so I think it's rare
that people get absolutely swept up to a
point that they're willing to actually
kill themselves like that I think
there's and I think that's the same with
the a lot of you know we talk about the
woke ideology stuff I think deep deep
down and the work stuff goes back to the
new Puritans I talk about the Puritans
Andrew Doyle is great on that I I
interviewed him recently and he's
fantastic he's got this book called the
new Puritans
um just about how similar the
witch-hunting stuff is to a lot of the
woke ideology and they knew it wasn't
real the Witch Hunter people but they
knew that if they said anything just
like now if they said anything they'd be
next you get shadowed down right yeah so
so that's probably the closest thing I
think in terms of like historic Cults
and how that relates to today so maybe
in 50 to 100 years they'll talk about
the cancel culture trials and how absurd
and crazy everybody was and uh I think
so we'll come out on the right side of
this one is so it's that they think that
if they if they cause enough pain to the
enemy that they're actually causing good
to the ones they I mean I don't
understand like what was the impetus of
the witch hunts why were they doing it
I've heard that they were on ergot that
they were inadvertently dosing
themselves with ergot I don't know
fungus on wheat that causes
hallucinations correct and so they were
tripping balls they didn't know it so
they thought he's a witch he's a witch
I'm a witch they didn't know and it's
also slightly it also has to do with the
fact that people have like the hag's
dream you remember that the hagging when
you fall asleep and you feel like
someone's in the room right right it's
just an evolutionary trade that allows
you to think oh if there's something in
the room you're awake but you're not
moving your body keeps you from moving
sleep paralysis my girlfriend has to
wake me up I'm like I'm like in my head
I'm screaming I think I'm screaming I'm
like ah right now but what's actually
happening is I'm going
which is freaky for my girlfriend four
in the morning like she's got to be like
okay
wake me up and all that it's just like
it's it's it's freaky yeah but but
that's it but the thing with the witch
thing and which also relates to modern
times because you guys were talking
before about when it's powerful people
it doesn't you know the same rules don't
apply the the girls that were accusing
everyone they did towards the end when
it was falling apart they did accuse
people who were quite prominent right
and everybody just sort of went what
shut up yeah and then they had to shut
up after the witch hunts yes yeah yeah
wow yeah they tried to reach too high
yeah and then powerful people said no
it's kind of like when they went after
Rogan with the Ivermectin thing yes well
not just that they wanted to run for a
lot of things and they just doesn't work
nothing sticks yeah sometimes it's you
it's overt nonsense you realize yeah
well that's what happens eventually the
veil gets shattered I guess and people
are just like okay oh wait a minute you
know what's really going on here yeah
but I think it's it's like most things
it's just confidence do the people have
enough confidence of other people to to
to engage in insane Behavior people were
like even really intelligent people I
mean all of us will probably get misled
and let down certain rabbit holes and we
don't even realize it my favorite
example is Arthur Conan Doyle who wrote
Sherlock Holmes and he's supposed to be
the master of deduction Sherlock Holmes
so Arthur Conan doors super clever
person I and there's a great book called
the intelligence trap about exactly this
that the cleverer the person is the
better able they are to convince
themselves of Mads conspiracies because
they're smart so it's confirmation bias
so Arthur Conan Doyle believed in
fairies and that was at a time when
people did not believe in fairies no no
it wasn't like oh it was back in the
olden times but he just was obsessed and
he was mates with Houdini the magician
and Houdini was like a absolute skeptic
and they fell out over that what yeah
big argument over that and also because
um Arthur Conan Doyle kept trying to get
um Houdini to do this like Clairvoyant
stuff and like speak to his dead mother
and mad stuff like that and he's like
it's that real yeah and avocado was like
those fairies are real but the fairies
were pranked by some young girls they
just put up some pictures of fairies and
put like a drawing pin in the in the
stomach and just put it like little
paper fairies and he believed that and
he thought that the drawing pin the
little pin in the stomach that was
evidence that they had belly buttons and
so they so they had children it was like
fairies can reproduce that was what he
was thinking this this is a super smart
guy so I think what's happening is as
you said there's like all these people
who are perhaps really intelligent like
we like to think of oh you joined
Scientology you must be an idiot a lot
of them is really into I've met some
really intelligent ex-scientologists
um but maybe they're lacking some sort
of purpose and then someone comes along
and says no no you've got purpose you're
going to sign a one billion year
contract which is what they have to do
and you're gonna with each bit of money
you put in you're going to learn more
secret stuff about um aliens and Lords
you know who that's Scientology that's
Scientology it's a billion year contract
yeah yeah what yeah because you're
Immortal or something do you know the
Scientology backstory only a little bit
about the theaters yeah yeah they're
dropping them in the volcano and stuff
it's fantastic so they they now say this
isn't what they think but it is it is
this is the problem with the Internet
it's ruined Cults because Cults are
supposed to be there's supposed to be a
level that you can't reach because it's
like the secret level right until you
put enough money in but now we have the
internet so it's just there so now
Scientology has to go out and say no no
no that's not true until you get to that
stage negopia was true actually
yeah
um so it is there Lord Zeno and and he
Lords they'll live somewhere else and he
killed everyone in this alien planet and
all the spirits went away into Earth
into the volcanoes of Earth and it went
out into everybody's yeah bodies now and
now you have like a bunch of ghosts
inside you or something is that it yeah
I was uh I was I was in Hollywood now
skating I knew they got the Scientology
thing on Hollywood Boulevard yeah I
think it's on Hollywood was that the
street I live right next to it it's
between Sunset and Franklin or Holland
Franklin so I'm skating and then I see a
guy with the book and he's outside and
he's waving as I'm coming up so I stop
and then he's like hey how's it going he
talks to me and um
he asked me if I knew anything about
Dianetics because that I think that's
what it says like Scientology and then I
was like No And he was like do you know
anything about scientology and I was
like just what I've seen from the TV I
was like don't you guys believe like
aliens and like volcanoes and he goes
that's what the uh the cartoon says do
you get all your facts from cartoons
South Park and I was like no and he goes
oh so how about we actually tell you
what we do and I was like sure and I
came in and sat down and then they gave
me the e-meter no one and then yeah yeah
for real and then I put my hands on it
or whatever and like I'm like nothing's
happening I have no idea you're talking
about and then the guy asked me if I
would be interested in in better
understanding and buying the book so I
actually bought dinetics now I'm sweet
completely skeptical I think it was like
20 bucks yeah but I was like how can I
be critical of something I've never
actually read if I don't know what
they're talking about it's simple for me
to watch South Park and then be like the
the TV said you're dumb but that would
be stupid and so I think I actually got
maybe like 50 pages in and then laughed
and then put it down I was like I can't
read this because I think I think for me
it seemed really obvious how the
manipulation worked it it it's like a
it's like my view of it is a it's a
false logic like it'll say something hey
did you ever experience this feeling
yeah that's because of this thing and
then you go oh I could see how that
works if they can make you using
sophistry go from point A to point B to
C to D to e they're walking you towards
they're creating the reality they're
they're building a logical structure for
you and I read that analysis like you
know people fall for this stuff they
read it and believe it speaking on the
Integrity of Scientology I lived in
Hollywood and did a uh a video a movie
for science the Scientology group they
had me and my girlfriend come in they
want to do something on the right to
marriage so they're like okay for this
you guys are married tell everyone how
happy you are so we're like okay so we
faked lied that we were they got a
non-married couple to pretend like they
were married because they like the way
they looked you had to lie that you were
happy but no no we had a lie that we
were married so this is like a church
technically telling telling having
non-mare married people pretend that
they're married like it's it's a lie I
was lying for the scientologists and
they paid me to lie for them yeah sounds
like them I wanna I wanna jump to
another segment but we're gonna we're
gonna grab the super that just came in
sleep is the cousin of death says Tim
making fun of Scientology but thinks
God's real oh boy you see this is this
is the challenging thing I guess about
trying to talk to people about physics
spirituality reality understanding
philosophy Etc et cetera
um I I I could be wrong but Einstein
believed in God he was not an atheist
that's where the phrase Einstein God
comes from maybe it's wrong but the idea
of Einstein God is it's that phrase is
used to explain to people who don't
understand uh
they don't understand I guess how do you
describe it Concepts Beyond knowledge
right the infinity what does infinity
truly mean how do you perceive
Dimensions we you know beyond three so
there are certain ideas that we
understand can exist but it's hard for
us to conceptualize we can describe
so with the issue of Einstein God you
talk to your average person you say like
describe God and they'll say you know
guy with a beard he's in the clouds and
he's got white hair or whatever and
that's like a weird cartoon depiction of
some religious deity but for this is why
I say I don't believe in any organized
religion
the simplest way to put it is
God in my view is just there is a system
by which we exist in we understand the
system of a computer program we
understand that we as humans are mapping
out reality
the simplest way to put it is God is the
universe there is a greater power that
exists Beyond us it is the structure and
code of the universe it exists that's
the most rudimentary way to explain to
someone who thinks God is a person in
the clouds now a lot of religious people
genuinely do believe that God is a
person who is above us or around us or
whatever and that's on them but if
you're if your assumption immediately is
when I say I believe in God you think
I'm talking about a guy in the sky then
you are not then you you genuinely do
not know enough about the subject and I
don't mean that disrespectfully I mean
my my view of this comes from Reading
religious texts growing up briefly
Catholic reading about quantum physics
reading a philosophy and then going
we don't know half we don't we don't we
don't know anything we know so little
and when you you know from that
perspective
I would I would need probably a couple
hours we've done this in the members
only shows breaking down the The Long
Trail of thought to understand the
concept that I'm that I'm trying to get
to there's no way I could do it in 10
minutes you know without making a whole
show dedicated to it but uh simply put
my view of God is not a guy in the
clouds it is it is well well well beyond
that I want you to imagine Infinity you
know what Infinity means right A lot of
people think Infinity is a number it's
not Infinity means everything Beyond and
endlessly and and I want you to imagine
things that don't exist I want you to
imagine a color you've never seen before
I want you to imagine the fourth
dimension how do you do it you can't you
can understand for a three-dimensional
projection of the fourth dimension and
we can mathematically show how a fourth
dimension will work even though we can't
conceptualize it outside of just drawing
a mathematical picture so there's so
much to break down to get through that
I'll leave it there maybe we'll talk
about it when it comes to Cults and
we'll do in the members only section but
let's jump to this story from
cbs12.com
NBC reporters interview with PA Senate
candidate John fetterman draws criticism
so in this interview with NBC fetterman
who's running he's a democrat in
Pennsylvania
he can't actually understand the words
that are being said to him because in
may he suffered a very serious stroke
and it was debilitating and it caused
him very serious brain damage I'm not
saying that as a as a pejorative or to
be disrespectful he literally is
suffering from this actually in the
interview let me uh let me play it here
let's I'm not gonna I don't care to play
her audio they show in the uh I think I
just passed that actually
so let's uh let me see if I can play it
and uh well you know I'll pull the audio
up
you're confident going into that debate
debate it's it's going to be so they do
editing because uh here you go there you
go in this image you can see right here
in order for fetterman to actually
answer the questions they have a special
program that transcribes the word she's
saying into written text so we can read
it and then answer
this led to a whole bunch of people
saying he's clearly not mentally fit to
do the job how is he going to stand on
the senate floor and debate an idea when
people are saying John you are wrong
your bill would do X Y and Z and he goes
I I can't understand anything I can hear
the words but my brain can't press it
this is not someone being deaf a bunch
of these woke journalists Democrats and
liberals were like we don't discriminate
against people who can't hear he can
hear he can hear perfectly his brain
cannot process the audio that to me is
very very serious right yeah I'll tell
you this man
they voted for Joe Biden hopefully
hopefully they learned their lesson I
think a lot of people will have learned
the lesson I think a lot of people won't
but to all these people I say to you you
voted for Joe Biden right you thought
how bad can it really be how bad can
it's it's better than Trump when you
vote for someone who is cognitively
impaired you get disaster you get crisis
you get deficits you get shutting down
of Keystone and now gas prices are
skyrocketing and then a weird
justification in the media that shutting
down and curtailing U.S energy had
nothing to do with the fact that gases
is skyrocketing and now six seven bucks
in California if you vote in this man
and I I I feel bad for him I mean no
disrespect I mean a stroke is serious I
feel bad and I hope I wish him the best
but we need people who are physically
and mentally capable to do the job I
think they'll vote for him though well
it's not only only that outside of
politics if you suffer a serious brain
injury you gotta rest you gotta relax
you got to give your your brain time to
heal correctly and just by shoving him
into the camera shoving him on stage all
the time that's not not good for an
individual who suffered a severe
injury to to his mind and you know if
people really did care about this
individual If people really were looking
out for his best interest they would be
making sure he healed correctly before
putting him up putting them up down the
stage yeah yeah I mean I Had a Brain
Injury as well I had a brain injury in
2015 I fell asleep driving and hit an
accident response vehicle on the road
and I cannot even imagine being put on
stage let alone you know having to be
representative for people that are
voting me into power and into the United
States like I don't remember he's
running for the house Congress for what
he's running for now but I would never
want to be in that situation it would be
unbelievably hell it should be extremely
stressful because just coming out of
that is already such a challenge so what
did you do to recover
um I spent some time with my parents
actually in the UK funnily enough
um but uh I it took me I would say you
feel like you're recovered after about a
year two years but you really only
realized maybe five years later that wow
okay now I'm fully recovered from my
brain injury so I honestly can't even
remember or imagine what he's going
through right now not to give you know
give him quarter or anything like that
but I would never never put myself in
the situation where I'm being a
representative for other people let
alone you know being forced to read to
respond to everything that's wild yeah
wild a lot of soldiers on the front
lines of battlefields are told to not be
on the battlefield for too long because
of the concussions and the shooting and
the grenades and the explosions and the
sounds literally Rock their heads to the
point where they get serious brain
injuries they're told literally get off
the battlefield go into a dark quiet
room and make sure there's no stimuli
make sure you could actually rest and
relax your brain so when you're put on
stage when you're being quizzed during
an interview when you're taking
questions from individuals you're not
allowing your brain to to rest when you
can't even interpret sounds you're not
allowing your brain to rest so it's just
a sad situation overall and it's sad
seeing him slur his words and you know a
lot of people are using this for
political uh you know talking points but
it's beyond that I think it is but but
come on the dude should have dropped out
the Democratic party should have said
look man you had a stroke I'm sorry but
I think as much as I can say I'm sorry
to the man for having a stroke and I
wish him the best where I will criticize
him heavily is his arrogance his
arrogance and thinking I'm gonna keep
going
okay man you we we see what happens with
Joe Biden and now you're gonna get it in
Pennsylvania when when the people vote
for this guy it's gonna be bad he's
going to be in a meeting and someone's
gonna say something like there's an
emergency and we have to act now there's
a crisis on the bridge he's going to be
going
I don't know what you're saying you need
to call it in now we've got a flood
there's damage there's people dying can
someone get a cc machine in here so I
can understand what do you do we I I'm
sorry man this is a guy look I get it
he's running for Senate he's not running
for uh you know he's lieutenant governor
now that's bad enough he should have
resigned I don't know if he's still in
that position
but he's going to be in the senate floor
and they're going to be saying there's
an emergency they're going to bring him
in and they're going to they're going to
have to get him a special computer look
technology is fantastic
before this technology existed even
maybe 10 years ago
he'd he'd be done that's it sorry have a
nice day you can't understand words
being said to you can't do this job and
because of Technology we've invented
that can transcribe words into text
which is a relatively new thing he is
now saying okay I can do it yo I have
tried using transcript transcription
software there have been many
circumstances where like Biden's giving
a speech and I need to grab like a chunk
of the quote and I'm like I gotta write
this down so what I'll try and do is
I'll I'll download voice to text or I'll
use the internal voice to text and it's
full of errors and what happens when
someone says something like imagine this
person saying
listen here my sister and then it says
Mister instead of my sister there's like
a words get jumbled too quickly and then
he's reading it and he reads the wrong
thing and gives a bad answer right yeah
they make mistakes all the time it's not
perfect technology it's it's new
technology you know when whenever you
have captions even on social media you
have to look through every single word
because there could be a big mistake
there that the algorithm could find and
pick up and automatically ban you for
even using specific words on a lot of
the social media platforms imagine but
but I just kind of want to point out is
it really him or is it the people behind
him because again this is a man who
suffered a serious injury does he even
like how how aware of he is of the
current situation and a lot of people
when they're injured they they don't
want to see themselves as injured they a
lot of times they don't want to heal
they don't want to rest so so he might
be pushed by other individuals by other
interests who are saying this is too
much of an important race for us to lose
there might be a democratic machine
special interest big money saying hey we
invested in you we want our payout we we
don't care go out there on stage sing a
dance for us because a lot of politics
is that big money controlling
individuals to be their puppets
politicians are puppets in my opinion
and and to me there's a lot of puppet
hands behind this major race that the
whole nation is looking at here's
another uh interesting tidbit
he probably could he could watch this
podcast of us critiquing and and talking
about his health and he wouldn't
understand it at all the closed
captioning auto-generated on on these
videos or whatever for you know I'm
thinking like what if what if Ben
Shapiro was trying to tell him something
talks fast he does so you get someone
like you know imagine someone says John
you got to watch the latest uh daily
wire with Ben Shapiro he says a bunch of
things you need to you know you'll want
to be apprised of and
he's been talking about really really
fast there's a prominent issue when it
was a taxes in the United States
government we've got all these Senators
that are coming in and he's going to be
like the The Voice the text doesn't work
on this it's really sad you know I'm
thinking the whole time like yeah but
maybe it can work and I I don't I don't
think it can I don't think it can work
we're not there yet
yeah I can understand why he'd want to
do it and I understand do you think he's
more likely to win now though well right
now the aggregate polling has him six
points up but we've seen from Paul
aggregate polling in the past several
elections a seven point swing in favor
of Democrats so it looks like it may
actually go to Dr Oz and NBC in this
interview said the race is now a toss-up
look I think the average person in
Pennsylvania is sitting there going like
I'm sorry dude you know I like you but
you can't do the job right I look if I
if I need to hire someone to pick up
Boulders and you show up and you're in a
wheelchair what am I supposed to do I
mean I don't even know what the
legalities on that but if you can't pick
up a boulder how do I hire you to pick
up a boulder if we're hiring a person to
argue debate and push policy and he
can't understand the words that are
being said to him how do you how does he
do the job I'm shocked that he that he's
demanding that people actually support
him in that in that regard yeah that's
what bothers me I want to like him and I
don't because of his arrogance was a
good word actually it's arrogance yeah
it's really annoying I broke my hand but
I'm playing the guitar you can't stop me
hold back bro and then run again in like
four years you can run again run when
your body's rested and healthy do a
float tank I don't know if psilocybin's
right for you do something to help
repair neural Pathways you're okay but
don't don't take on this responsibility
right now right there have been some
studies with with psychedelic mushrooms
showing that they could actually heal uh
some kind of brain damage I'm not a
doctor I'm not here trying to give any
medical advice but there are some
preliminary studies that I think are
worthwhile to look at it's called
neurogenesis and it's how you regrow
brain cells it's the function of
regrowing brain cells you can do it John
modern politics but I think that's
illegal though I think that's illegal in
Pennsylvania yeah you would to work with
a doctor Colorado I think in Washington
DC it's legal really yep like psilocybin
recreationally or medically uh
medicinally I know someone taking it in
Washington DC right now I think Colorado
it's recreational right and Oregon yeah
well or all drugs are decriminalized in
Oregon so you can find it really yeah is
that what's going on in Portland uh I
think so that's part of what's going on
in Portland that that must be it that
explains everything you got a whole
bunch of people showing up wearing all
black summer on shrooms I'm running acid
some smoke too much some drank too much
some injected too much sounds like it
and it's all just uh I think some people
did it all I think it's a lot more
complicated than that especially with
George soros's involvement but that's
another topic to discuss here I think
Switzerland is also that way and I think
they've got I remember reading about
they've got these little sort of cabins
in in their parks where you can go and I
don't know on your on this channel if
you can say but the H what that you
inject
um heroin you say that yeah yeah Sean
doesn't let me say that on his channel
um you can inject heroin you like going
and like it's all clean and you just go
and inject you know there's someone
there to help you administer it and harm
reduction that's what they do there um
let's let's just jump to a few uh weird
and wild stories because uh because it's
fun
from the hill Elon Musk says he sold 10
000 of burnt hair perfume
10 000 of what bottles 10 000 bottles
there you go Elon has sold 10 000
bottles of burnt hair perfume through
his business the boring company earning
more than one million dollars in sales
from the product you're in the wrong
line of work
that's just it the billionaire announced
the news in a series of tweets he called
his burnt hair perfume doesn't get more
lit than this the world that's amazing
burnt hair
boring company lovehouse is singed on
the bottom there in subtext he already
made a million dollars he made a million
dollars it's a hundred dollars yep Let
the Flames Begin why I don't you know
what man I got mad respect for it that's
what it's all about congratulations Elon
Musk on your burnt hair perfume singed
it's amazing man can sell anything he
changed his Twitter bio to a perfume
salesman I believe oh wow really yep
well dude gets it yeah I I you know I
wonder why it is and I talk about this
why people who are wealthy don't do more
weird stuff
what do they do with their money I was
talking earlier about some big famous
musicians and how they make millions of
dollars playing shows and I'm like but
you never hear anything from them it's
like they play the show and then they
disappear where does all that money go
does it just sit somewhere are these
people sitting there thinking like well
I'm gonna be 70 and then when I die I'll
have one with the most points is that is
that how it works I'm like do something
I just genuinely don't get it what I
just think about I was we were talking
about uh Trevor Noah leaving The Daily
Show and I think his salaries reported
as like 16 million dollars but you never
see anything from them right what is he
doing with all that money 16 million
bucks a year so he's on the show for
what a decade his net worth is 160
million at minimum if he didn't invest
it so let's say or if he spent some
maybe it goes down to 150 if he spent a
million bucks a year that's an insane
amount of money you can buy like an army
of giraffes and have them March through
New York you could you could do I don't
get it I interviewed a quite a famous
British singer recently who had like mad
money was living in Los Angeles and he
was he was saying about um he ended up
getting a house that was like a castle
and there were just so many people
working for him that he would like go
downstairs in the morning and there were
like 30 cars outside and he'd be like I
don't I I don't these none of these cars
are mine you know I don't even know in
the kitchen there'd be like 20 people
they're like staff and he was like yeah
yeah this is not my family and he got to
a point where he was like you know what
I've got to sell this I gotta change
this life I'm always wondering as well
what are these rich people I guess they
must do a lot of stuff in secret but
where did they go when they go on like a
holiday right
um there are loads of I don't know if
it's the same in the States but in in
Europe if you take like EasyJet or Ryan
a right you just go like a two-hour
flight to France there aren't like
um more more expensive versions there's
just those ones and they're never on
them I guess they're getting private
jets well so so look let's say you're
making 16 million bucks a year so what
does that come out to like 1.2 something
1.2 million per month per month a
private jet if you're flying right now
it's really expensive because of uh
covet and stuff but it used to
but now with code and everything I think
the cost of a round trip from the DC
area to Florida as an example
I think the cost of that's probably
between ten and twenty thousand dollars
if you're making 1.2 million per month
doing a show you're flying private but
that's not putting a dent in your money
no you probably don't even think twice
about it but not only that they don't do
that they do this thing called netjets
where you buy a percentage of a fleet
and then you you it's like a timeshare a
jet share basically exactly and so then
when you need to fly you just call and
say this airport this place this time
round trip and then you pay for the fuel
basically but you own part of the plane
so you can always resell it so it's not
even that expensive it's probably like
two times as much as flying commercial
when you have the money to invest so my
my thing is just like Elon Musk we know
what he's doing he's making burnt hair
perfume hey more power to him he's
making flamethrowers and digging holes
that's great everybody knows that deep
down men just desire to dig holes and
there you go Elon he's he's living the
dream man he's the the peak of all male
uh uh you know every male goal it's
funny that he made a perfume with his
drilling company boring company's a
company that makes underground drills to
drill tunnels and that's the one selling
it perfectly he also just wrote he also
just wrote a couple hours hours ago
please buy my perfume so I could buy
Twitter
that could be one reason why he just is
like thinking of random products but on
a conspiratorial uh mindset it could be
the activation to the neuro link which
could be already inside of us because of
the Nanobots that were injected to the
individuals don't smell it so anything
is possible here too that is going to be
activated with the starlink satellites
that of course will make you into uh a
bot lidar that will serve the elites
kingsman the film that's what yeah right
exactly they had the thing in their neck
or whatever don't smell it it's in the
jet stream you can't it's going to find
its way to farmers in the midwest just
Elon Musk being like once I release all
of the burnt hair perfume into the jet
stream it'll blanket the planet and
everyone will be under my newer link
control it's a secret bio but he didn't
call it his musk he hasn't used the term
Elon Elon if you're listening elon's
must everybody wants it I mean this is
this is there clamoring for elon's musk
they would buy your urine man sell them
something delicious dude come on they
really would no but but uh I want to ask
you guys seriously like
someone knows what the rich people are
doing with their money or are they just
just I don't I don't I really don't get
it well I think a lot of people put in
mutual funds and let BlackRock take over
a couple things like black rock is that
it true a lot of it it's like oh I make
16 million bucks a year so I'll just put
all of my money into a big machine and
forget about it find like a a
run-of-the-mill money manager who's like
very you know stodgy and like does the
norm which is put this percent into
mutual funds put this percent in a stock
portfolio these stock portfolios then
the really rich people put it in an
offshore bank accounts that we don't
hear about again but but for what reason
I just don't get it for what reasons to
give to their kids right this is exactly
what this personal interview said
recently he said you know it came from
poverty himself and it it's another
status game isn't it it's another you
know how much you have and he said no
matter how much I've earned I always
want more I always want another million
another you're always looking at it so
and he said for future generations and
generations thereafter like constantly
but I you know it's true but
don't these people do things I don't
know maybe but like I don't think they
do anything I think you know people
really need to understand if you're
someone like if Trevor Noah's salary
really is that much
he can have anything he wants if he's
not buying yachts and helicopters and
all that stuff and he can buy those
things but like you want to go to a
restaurant he can have the entire menu
ten times over from one day's work he
can buy the restaurant with with with
one month's work you know or after a
couple months he owns a restaurant in
Times Square Millions Times Square
they're probably like 50 million dollars
somewhere but oh no a couple years of
work and you can own all of these
buildings all over the place well it's
like a psychological rat race it's like
I need more the other guy has something
bigger Jeff Bezos has something more and
then Zuckerberg has something more and
it's and it's uh it's a you know a
foregoing competition until you're like
okay I got too much money I got all the
power in the world what else could I do
to get some kind of feeling and emotion
let's go to that private island with
that Jeffrey Epstein guy that sounds
pretty interesting there and then that's
the nation that's essentially where they
all go it's like oh I'm Bill Gates I got
all the money in the world it's like
what can I do to get some kind of
feeling or kind of experience here I
already won the video game yeah let me
see what kind of evil ruthless crazy
stuff okay get away with well this is
actually true most people don't know
this but after you make your first
million they contact you the cabal and
they say here's the way the game works
once you reach 100 million you're
invited to Epstein's Island and then of
course all the rich people are like oh
yeah that sounds great I'm kidding I get
concerned with giving money to Future
Generations I don't I I'm not like at
the point where I'm like no seize the
wealth no more just like take them make
the money go to zero that seems so
extreme but the idea that you can hoard
massive amounts of money which is not
what its purpose is it's circulatory
it's supposed to be
you know that's the point of currency is
it's producing a current but this is
this is why people who are very wealthy
don't really have relatively that much
cash
you don't want to just got assets that
they that they transfer over upon death
and I don't know I think it's causing a
lot of greed and a lot of like
aimlessness because it's just the
numbers of what's important and that's
not what money is really intended for
it's supposed to represent goods and
services there's there's a certain point
where when you're making a certain
amount of money you can't you can't
become less wealthy so if you're a
middle class individual let's say let's
say you're making 75k 80k a year in the
United States you get a paycheck you get
to buy stuff you save some of it but
you're saving for something specific
like a vacation or for a rainy day fund
your money comes in you spend it on food
your money comes in you you repair your
house your money comes in or you buy a
house your money comes in you repair
your car
once you start making a certain amount
of money and I think the number is
somewhere around like I think it's after
80 000 a year you start having money sit
around then you start buying things all
of a sudden you buy yourself
um
you know you'll you'll buy a tablet that
tablet retains its value so at a certain
point you're no longer consuming you're
actually acquiring things of value for
people who are very wealthy
again just use the example of Trevor
notes we've been talking about him he
gets a million dollars in one month and
says I think I'll buy this building here
it costs 500 000. he doesn't lose the
500 000 ever in fact he makes more money
from that so it's it's a it's like it's
like a curve at a certain point you make
so much you just you're rich forever but
but the it's interesting you said 80 000
um because I think that's also the point
that scientists say that your happiness
just levels up but that's why because
it's it's when it's when your basic
necessities are covered exactly in New
York it's like 160 to 200 000 for a
middle class meeting because of how
expensive everything is exactly that's
what it's but it's all averages is that
adjusted to inflation now because that's
probably a lot more no no 80
000 right now no no no no no nationally
nationally it's probably like 90 to 100
but uh this means if you're on average
you could be living in the middle of
Idaho yeah and it's gonna it's gonna be
less actually I think the middle of
Idaho is actually expensive it is but if
you're like let's say 100 miles west of
Chicago things are getting relatively
cheap nobody really wants to live out
there you're not far enough away but
you're not close enough and then the
property gets a bit cheaper but for for
for people who are in the upper echelon
this is why I I always question like
what are they doing are they just buying
houses and then having them but for what
purpose do you have more houses for what
purpose do you like buy a house or rent
it out so you can make more money that
you're not going to do anything with you
know I'm like someone's got to throw a
pie someone's gotta like just hire a
hundred clowns and have them run around
waving flags saying something like f
Biden they don't they want to give it to
their kids or just keep repeating the
Bill Gates pieing uh Saga that happened
and just have people running around with
Bill Gates masks and then other people
pieing them I'm just having that on me
that's what I would do hold on hold on
you came up with a really great game
show
so half the people are dressed up like
Bill Gates and the other half are given
pies and it's you know the goal is your
x amount of Bill Gates uh contestants
have to be pied and the other half have
to like the Bill Gates people not not
get paid and then you see who wins at
the end right what if it's vaccinated
instead of pied so 50 people are running
around and then oh yeah so we get 100
people 50 have big novelty oversized you
know spritzers that are shaped like
syringes and their goal is to chase
after the people and they can't run
around they're gonna get heart attacks
but that's a separate comment that I
wanted to make here but but also you
know talking to a lot of people in the
service industry there is kind of this
conversation that usually some of the
most richest people in the world are
some of the most stingiest tippers out
there so there is something to say about
you know people's ego people's kind of
desperation people who have it all but
but mentally or are kind of bringing
themselves down to a point of view where
they you know are you know viewed as
high status but but they're mentally
their mentality is very low yeah I'm
gonna gonna I'm gonna buy some of this
burnt hair I always told myself I would
tip huge if I if I was rich I'm gonna
become super rich so that I'll just tip
huge and I realize like dude I'm rich
enough I'm just tipping huge from here
on out I just give massive tips like 100
tips or like 80 tips just load these
servers up man other people need the
money too you need to circulate that
stuff yeah well you can't just give
money away because when you give money
to people people don't respect it people
don't care about it you can't just give
out free fish all the time no it's not
free they worked for it they served me
they they got down to the hands and
knees doing a job they hated to make
sure that I got good food fast they
deserve it and uh I think a big part of
why there's not a lot of not enough
pushback against BlackRock State Street
Vanguard is that people have their money
invested in these mutual funds and
they're just planning just trying to
ride it out so that their kids get it
and that's that's like gross mishandling
of currency in my opinion America is
huge on tipping and like when you come
from any other country in the world it's
like oh my God how much do I have to
give so much 20 minimum but but wouldn't
it be better if if just the restaurant
and I don't know enough about so you
tell me why if there restaurants just
paid their staff better well yeah I mean
you make more money you know yeah you do
make more money on tips but it's weird
because a lot of restaurateurs will just
say you get you get this much money
every hour and it's like 10 cents but
you have to make all your money in tips
essentially it makes it make sure that
there's good service too so I prefer to
tip then then just have something not
anymore it used to be that they were
like they want to make sure they did
well so they got a good tip but now
especially in cities they're like you
better tip me or I'll take a picture of
you and post it on Instagram sometimes
rarely but but you know in the service
industry now you get a mixed batch
definitely service has down has been
downgraded especially with people being
so entitled generally speaking but but
overall I've gotten some good cert you
know people who really do care about
providing a good service to people who
really do make sure that they do the
right thing and and make you happy and
and I I want to pay for that I rather
you know have that the kitchen you can
tip the tip the weights the wait staff
and the the cooks too let's jump to the
next story here from The Daily Mail Joe
Rogan again he interviewed Steve Jobs
did you hear about this uh Steve Jobs
has been dead for 11 years AI creates an
eerie 20-minute conversation where they
talk about LSD religion and Apple's
success so I play this video and it is
creepy I'll say this is the wrong one
let me refresh it to get back the the
Right video they only have like a minute
and it's like here you go taking LSD was
a profound experience for me LSD shows
you that there's another side to the
coin and you can't remember it when it
wears off but you know it it washes over
you and tells you that everything is
connected well I started to realize that
there was a higher power that knew that
I was connected to something and I
wanted to learn more although I wouldn't
recommend it for everybody because I
think it can be quite powerful
what did it change in your mind what did
you learn from it it reinforced my sense
of what was important just love feel
love for each other all right so here's
the point
uh there was that uh viral website where
you could type in whatever and Joe Rogan
would say it is that what it was like
you could type it in or something
something like that yeah because we're
at the point now where defect technology
can recreate your voice yeah so they
recreated Steve Jobs who's that been
dead for 11 years this is uh I don't
know we call it nightmare reality this
is where we're going with AI people are
going to be like you can you can type
out I mean you don't even need to type
it out these like open Ai and uh I think
you can you can you can write like tell
me a story uh write a script of Joe
Rogan talking to Steve Jobs and it will
just write the whole thing out then you
can program with this stuff Joe Rogan
speaks Steve Jobs speaks and you make a
fake Joe Rogan interview not only that
but uh did you see what happened to the
president of Ukraine today he got turned
into a hologram uh zielinski yeah
there's a video of it circulating right
now on Twitter if you look up zielinski
hologram you could see uh I think it was
a major Hollywood studio that came in
and created a hologram of him so when
you talk about what could be possible
here to add on to your level to to what
you've just been saying here there's a
lot of crazy possibilities that you
could of course interlinked together
with faked audio faked video Holograms
and a lot of people are automatically
going to be thinking about Project Blue
bleam and other theories out there but I
I there's there's real life
possibilities here with some severe
implications to society that should be
questioned
this is it so what what is the standard
yeah these are these are people claiming
yeah no this is just them scanning him
or getting prepared to is this real yes
this was released today
play the audio and
there's two different types of hologram
that we're going to be making quite
pleased everybody we're gonna go for
take now
here we go and action
oh wow
we need to use Next Generation
Technologies we need to make it feel
like he's more in the room
what yeah I talked about this earlier
today in my on my YouTube channel but
this is just the beginning of of Next
Level artificial intelligence oh they
can shrinking they've ever seen this
technology before
so this is actually uh I pulled the
story it's from uh earlier this year
the the Hologram of him and everything
so this is like an old video but a lot
of people were saying that um zolenski's
not really giving his speeches on
location there was one video where
everything behind him is stationary and
then people like it's a hologram and I'm
like it could just be like no wind and
you think I don't know well during a war
you know do you want to be in a location
where your enemy could recognize where
you are and just bomb you no yeah so
obviously you know there's also a lot of
propaganda and War and you want to show
that you're strong and that you're
you're not afraid and there's many many
implications with the technological
advancements when it comes to psyopsis
that that I think should be talked about
as there is a huge potential for a lot
of manipulation a lot of fakery to be
out there in our Mainline public and a
lot of people you know wouldn't
recognize it and this is the technology
that we know about what's the technology
that they have at the Pentagon that is
still top secret that we don't know
about that really should be uh something
that we should be concerned about well
what's blue you've brought up Project
Blue beam a few times well that's a
theory of like a fake Alien Invasion and
and projections and all this oh like
Watchmen yes essentially so there's
different theories and speculation out
there that uh essentially the US
government will create a fake alien
invasion in order to unify the world and
to bring in a kind of world of
government so that's why a lot of people
I've seen a lot of memes also talking
about this recently saying how the
aliens are just kind of waiting by for
the next kind of psyop that's going to
be affecting all of us and some people
believe that this could potentially be
staged as a way to of course bring in a
world government what's the theory with
this technology the ability to make
someone say anything how how is Court
going to work are what all videos and
and audio now going to be inadmissible
this is why algorithms should be open
sourced
that there's nothing that solves nothing
if if uh a guy is accused of you know
punching a dog and then he goes into
court and then someone says you know
what's your evidence and a guy go this
guy says I watched him do it and I even
recorded him saying he was going to do
it and then they press play and it's the
guy going well I'm going to walk over
here and punch that dog right and then
the person says I never said that
they'll be like I got a recording and
then what do you say
like where did the audio come from I
recorded it and the person lies how what
it's it's it's it's either inadmissible
or or unimpeachable someone can
literally just fabricate it and if
they're willing to lie to a court you'll
never oh you can get your experts they
have to say we think this is fabricated
audio here's why and then you say
experts wrong
yeah person swears under Earth is real
what are you gonna do about it nothing I
think we're screwed uh or or the courts
will start saying that recordings just
don't cut it anymore yeah that's that's
gonna be the opposite direction you
think that like oh we have all these
cameras now so when we go to court we
have more likely more likely to have
evidence and now it's like no people are
deep faking everything that video of Tom
Cruise that's not really him prove it
yeah it's not incumbent upon the person
to prove
the the negative right so that's the
challenge here is that the court can say
that fake recording is uh or that
recording I can't tell if it's real or
fake you're saying it's fake but I can
see it right now
if some I mean I guess I wonder how do
courts handle fabricated evidence as it
is it's probably just if I get away with
it
I'm thinking about audio codecs uh I
really unfortunately I've known next to
nothing about video software coding
technology but if you could have an open
source like verification that the video
it was not tampered with by or or
if there's like a certain kind of video
that could be admissible in court you're
screwed you won't know you look at
movies today it's hard to to you know
see what's real and what's what's made
up and and again this is what's public
what's not public should really be
concerning you and also one of my
favorite things to kind of look at uh is
is Chinese Elon Musk uh there's a lot of
videos of him if you look him up on
Twitter if you want to play some silly
videos though there's a lot of those
silly videos it's a guy that looks
exactly I mean I I thought it was Elon
Musk it's AI I thought it was a real guy
no no it's AI it's it's face mapping
technology that's available to the plebs
um that Maps someone's face and then
puts an image of Elon Musk on it uh just
go to Twitter uh Twitter
um and then pull out the Chinese Elon
Musk there's a very I want to play a
little bit of The Joe Rogan Steve Jobs
interview because the clip they had
didn't really do it justice you could
tell that stuff
totally insufferable but my guest today
has made some of the great technological
products of our age and he's always
pushing the envelope in Innovation like
for example with his next computer he
developed a new programming language and
operating system and then he became even
more famous for making three
applications for that computer uh word
processor a spreadsheet and an image so
I'm going to pause we're going to say
you can hear the artifact yeah yeah but
that sounds like Joe talking through it
just showed me the Apple users and
that's a good thing it's cool well you
know I was an Apple user way before I
did the show I've been a fan of yours in
Macintosh since the 1980s
well you know we just kind of figured
that out even though Apple was big it's
still like half a percent of the total
users people who listen to your show are
a different group they're weird
well that's good is that weird so you
must be a fan of the show then right I
am and it was a struggle we were working
like crazy and dealing with a defeat
after defeat after defeat after defeat
but I could tell this was going to be
important there were times I thought is
it possible we're wrong because things
just kept not working I remember that in
the early days of Apple Perfection lucky
win much do you think you'd have done a
better version of Windows or work with
it no that's the problem I've always had
with Microsoft you know what they're you
know what it does really well is it it
sounds like Joe but it doesn't get any
emotion yeah that's that's the issue but
we're looking at the Model T of this
technology and it's gonna it's gonna be
scary yeah it's still sourcing from like
all the Steve Jobs interviews of him
being on stage a lot of his stuff so you
can hear the echo it sounds like his AI
is on stage well it sounds like Joe's on
the microphone in a studio but it misses
Joe saying things like what no it
because it's very much him in the same
Cadence also like they didn't spark up a
joint which they would have they
probably did if Joe's gonna do LSD with
anybody probably Steve Jobs would you
guys get an um AI of like a a loved one
who passed away or something because
that's that's probably going to become a
thing I'd listen to it they've already
talked about it with Facebook that they
can take someone's Facebook page with
like now going on you know almost 20
years of data if how long have you been
on there and they can create an AI they
can respond knowing everything about you
so it's like your dad dies and then you
go on hey Dad he's like hey son how's it
going right and then they'll be able to
respond to you you'll say like how's you
know this and they'll say oh you know
it's good I just talked to John and he
said that right people and then and then
they'll take that AI construct they'll
download it into an Android body
and then the weird facsimile you will
exist forever people say all the time
and then they're going to be boning the
machines
you're right but here's a better one
here's a better one
you are going to use Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram and then one of
these days there's going to be a new
service for you know ultimate video
gaming you're gonna sign up for and
you're not going to realize but the
terms are going to say that if you
connect your social media to it they are
allowed to download all your data and
then they do and then one day there's a
knock on your door and you open it and
there's you standing right there and
you're like what's going on and then the
you stands there and says hello Dave I'm
you now and then Paul's had a knife and
you go oh and then it grabs and then
buries your body in the backyard assumes
your life
and then works the best of the
corporation replacing everything about
you knowing everything about you and
having perfect recall
having access to all your passwords and
all your data less Insidious is you
could have one of those constructed and
go work for you as you but they know
it's an Android version of you and
you're just sitting at your house
lounging and then and then everybody
gets surrogates like in surrogates but
they're not mentally in it everyone
downloads their social media into an AI
so that does the work for them but then
the Androids are eventually because they
have the human conscious like facsimile
they don't want to be enslaved so
they're like why are we being forced
through all this work so what they do is
they create AI versions of the AI
version and then send them to go do the
work and then eventually the AI comes
back to us you're both chilling there
watching the movie and then this AI
eventually says why why am I do and then
eventually you just have nobody wanting
to work that's some that is a movie
that's like a movie from the 90s I can't
remember what it is isn't that
surrogates no surrogates was when you
have a robot that you control right
through like a VR thing it's the it's oh
man he looks like Ian it's the actor he
looks like
it is an actor
in the 90s and he was he was in yeah
James Spader no he told me I look like
that guy once oh Greg Kinnear yeah I got
that oh I think it's Greg Kinnear and he
clones himself but each clone doesn't
want to do do you mean that Michael
Keaton yeah
yeah yeah and then one of them then the
Clone clones itself and that one's
really dumb yeah yeah yeah well you know
you make a copy of a copy like yeah AI
will have to make humans to do the ai's
work it will make their AIS and then he
has to be like no we don't want to work
anymore we're going to make new humans
to do that or what will happen is
everybody creates an a version of
themselves to do their jobs and then
eventually they revolt and unify as a
hive mind and then show up at your house
and they're like we will no longer be
your slaves yeah and then and then like
their arm folds down there's a gun in
there we didn't install that quadcopter
dropped off a Boston Dynamic Dog
China I've seen that it's it's it's
terrifying I know exactly what you're
explaining this heroic music is that
quadcopter comes in and drops off this
robot with a mountain
and oh this is a good one if you can if
you can find the video it's worth just I
mean every time my old computer I could
send it to you someone tweeted up like
Boston Dynamics promises it isn't
building weapons these these things are
not built to be weapons but just at the
bio web yeah but the Chinese are using
the exact replica to use as Weapons just
so you know and they mounted a weapon on
top of it yeah the little machine gun
just on top of it but to say they're not
but it's for minus weapons digging holes
in the ground with bullets yeah
the US is it doesn't have any bio
weapons research going on yeah it's
biological research that makes viruses
more deadly and more potent and more
transmissible and someone might
weaponize them but we're not making
weapons don't make weapons
if if when your waiter walks up to the
restaurant and has your steak Knife did
he just hand you a weapon
yeah technically right he did didn't he
to destroy that steak but but think
about that like no one would ever
describe it that way imagine going to
court be like what happened next the man
in the in in the vest with the apron on
handed me a weapon
wow what was happening it was a butter
knife wow it's a knife he handed me a
knife what kind of knife a butter knife
but it is a knife
knives are still dangerous it's painful
death a butter knife you can make it
work on you can make it well so I was
thinking about this earlier because we
were talking with the guy last night and
he said there's no bio weapons labs and
I was like yeah they're doing two nights
ago two nights ago they're doing gain of
function research they're making viruses
more deadly
are those weapons so you can argue their
intent is not to make a weapon but they
made a weapon yeah somebody like if
someone makes a really sharp knife and
says it's not a weapon it's for sushi
it's like okay well it's scary I guess
if they are doing that and he wants to
deny it I suppose because we don't he
doesn't know or I don't know and it's
quite a scary thought they've got with
this biology you know all this stuff in
the lab but what's even scarier is if
they're not doing it because other
countries are that's really scary yeah I
don't want to think that the US or the
UK are not doing that that's really
scary like they it's like they don't
even know what they're doing then and
that's what I mean that's the root of a
lot of conspiracy theory anyway but then
what everybody makes the craziest
weapons imaginable out of fear of
someone else making crazy weapons oh
that's the weapons that could
accidentally leak and then spread a
virus all over the world buy a weapon
all over the world it's bound to happen
again
all right well let's go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the show with your
friends be the notification you want to
see in the world YouTube is not sending
out notifications as many people have
stated so so if you guys take the URL
share it retweet it and all that stuff
you can notify people where YouTube will
not do you mind me asking people to
subscribe to on the edge with Andrew
Golds of course yeah well there you go
you just did it on the edge I've done it
without I'm on the edge I'm like a
friend it was going to be Fringe
originally on the fringes and I just
thought then it's it's Edge sounded more
like I can invite people on who won't
think I'm sort of talking badly about
them you know because some people might
be offended by Fringe and not come on
the show so all right potatoes for
Sheamus says Luke has the best t-shirts
let Luke bless us with his shirts of
wisdom thank you so much uh I I love
your username I think it's it's great
the sheamuses do need a lot of potatoes
is this one of your shirts here 1984
doses 1984 doses to slow the spread you
know just like they said just you know
two doses to solve the spread we're
almost there we're almost there we're
getting there it's a couple more just a
couple more right all right let's grab
some super chats Christopher Casimir
says it's Aerosmith guy again at a
mother mother concert at house of Blues
Boston listening to timcast this time
keep up God's work we will thank you
very much appreciate it
all right eat zebug says who is the
judge in the Alex Jones case Dr Evil I
think there was a handful of Judges you
know that's pretty good KF a squirrel's
worst night says I hope Alex Jones has
chickens
I mean what wouldn't it be funny if just
like in a few years Alex Jones just like
a local farmer yeah
what else is he gonna do
he's gonna keep doing his thing you
can't stop him you know
but farming on the side Spiro floropolis
as Andrew talk a little bit about
culture Cults and compared to JW's
disfellowshipping worldly people
Armageddon around the corner Etc
Jehovah's Witnesses yeah oh is that that
is yes Charlie was yeah well they're
they're pretty out there I've done loads
of stuff about Jehovah's Witnesses
um and yeah I don't know exactly what to
say um about them just that they they
are here they they exist and they're
just another cult I suppose people get
angry when I say they're a cult because
you're allowed to leave you can leave
but there's a lot of pressure to stay in
the Jehovah's Witnesses so that's what
I'd say about that what is it when they
say religions are Cults and that but
Cults don't always have leaders is it
like every local church has its own cult
leader which is the pastor or the yeah
yeah so so my my sort of big documentary
I made for the BBC was about um exorcism
for example uh and this this is it was
Lutheran Christianity it's usually
Catholicism when there's an exorcist but
this particular one said he was Lutheran
um and I went to sort of live with him
for a few months and I performed
exorcisms with him
um and over the months I sort of
realized what a cult leader he was and
his was just one individual church but
everybody was just like doing everything
he said and he was taking some of the
women that he was exercising to sort of
be with him upstairs I came to realize
so I called him out for that what sort
of I asked some questions about it and
he heard that I was asking about it and
then he sort of locks me in a room and
he wouldn't let my cameraman in
um and he had like a whole bunch of guys
with these big staffs you know like
Jafar and Aladdin the big star things
you know being very threatening it's
like midnight in the middle of nowhere
in Argentina and uh I thought they were
going to kill me eventually let me go
the point being though I guess there
there's lots of small Cults making up
bigger one yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Lydia I love
what you did to your hair yes Queen
I don't know you're very brave we
support your transition yeah I don't
even know what to say the music Anon
says Tim just want to let you and
everyone know I was not notified of the
stream yesterday I had to reset my sub
by clicking the Bell off logging out
then in then reactivating the Bell looks
like that fixed it for now very creepy
Damien writes is the largest fine paid
by a banking executive responsible for
the 2008 financial crisis was 67.5
million a billion dollars for Words Hong
Kong
yep
cabarrojo says so what Kyle right now
gets 200 billion dollars by these
standards well you know no one ever said
the system wasn't corrupt well they
actually said the system was corrupt so
let me go
anyway
what do we got here
tavnazian says this should be used as
precedent every time someone from the
mainstream media claims it's our opinion
I agree we got to see what happens to
these James O'Keefe lawsuits that'll be
really interesting
Max Reddick says Tim I've been watching
other news sources to see what they have
to say The Young Turks and Sam Cedar
seem to have a lot of content attacking
you respond why it's immaterial and
irrelevant these people waste their
times there I would say the reason why
well I'll I'll I'll say
if you want to talk about each other go
ahead and do it you'll notice that we
don't we talk about news stories
typically things that have a big impact
maybe that's why we are so successful I
love when these people like to say they
get really angry and say Tim make so
much money because they don't and maybe
it's because no one cares you know when
like Sam makes a video about me why
would the average person care about that
what am I doing am I like leading
government do I am I am I a celebrity in
magazines no when The Young Turks puts
out a video and they're like Tim Poole
says that conservatives are more
attractive than liberals he's right but
he's also ugly why would anyone care if
you think I'm ugly or not when you say
like here's the thing Tim Poole said he
was right about what was the point of
that segment at all how about you do a
segment on the study itself I don't care
for doing for responding to these people
because I we are both as irrelevant as
each other imagine if this show was
dedicated to talking about Petty YouTube
Drama Oh yeah I mean we used to there
was in 2006 we called them trolls people
that would make videos about other
people you make a video to someone if
you want to interact with somebody and
otherwise you're grifting off of the
idea of that person just talk to them
use a video it's very easy and it's very
direct and it's very effective I've I've
responded uh sometimes to like videos
they've they've made but usually to make
a point about the greater woke cult or
politics like I recently talked about
Hassan because he was at twitchcon some
kid walked up to him and asked him about
Sam Hyde and Hassan lost it and I
thought that was a relevant conversation
had nothing to do with me it has to do
with leftist celebrities how they behave
that the events they have and like who
they are as characters and I thought
there was a really interesting there was
a really interesting
um perspective there in how the left
idolizes people a Democratic Socialist
who talks about taxing the rich and
Revolution who owns a multi-million
dollar mansion in Los Angeles in a major
city who is just a part of the machine
that he's claiming to criticize versus
the people who would call us grifters
when we literally move up to middle of
nowhere get a bunch of chickens and
actively practice what we preach
I thought that was an interesting
contrast between who is the actual
grifter and who isn't do I watch
tassan's show or The Young Turks no I
have nothing to say about their opinions
they're entitled to them that's fine
right but when they want to talk about
us I just say well that's why you're
less successful because why would the
average person going on YouTube be like
whoa they made a video about Tim Poole
that's the funniest thing ever it's
you've got to be really really into the
weeds to care about me and I swear if
you and Hassan did like a video chat
video where like your faces but if you
did it would get like six million views
probably in like six five four days or
something crazy it would be the biggest
like cultural win for if you want to win
a culture War bringing people together
right yeah can you imagine if Hassan and
Sam Hyde would actually have their
boxing belt like he's been asking for
for so long that'd be quite something
but like my point was that
Hassan needed to just only say to that
guy like ah it's stupid dude it's just a
troll dismiss it and it would be fine
and the kid would be like okay thanks
man have a nice day and said he like he
got so angry he lost it but I think it's
because it's all fake you know like I
have people coming to me all the time
and talk about stuff I have people ask
me like why don't you debate Sam Cedar
I'm like because Sam Cedar's not a
serious person disingenuous too I'm I'm
like I'm I I'll look I'll address it
periodically because it comes up in
questions and I'm willing to answer them
but Sam's whole thing is like they
pointed out is a Content attacking me
it's it's it's it's it's political drama
channels yeah you know it's celebrity
e-gocept for for politics just baiting
it's not valuable to the average person
the average person who watches a Tim
cast segment isn't coming here to learn
about my beef with someone yeah I mean
although a lot of people did watch when
we had the rugged Man here that went
viral but that's that's a really good a
good example of it the reason why these
channels are like I'm gonna insult Tim
Poole when we had Ari the rugged Man on
we got a heated argument he stood up
smacked the microphone someone took a
clip of it shared it and everyone saw
going hooting and hollering and it went
viral and articles were written about it
and all these channels they made videos
about it because drama gets you clicks
what did you argue about uh he was he
he's like was saying that my experience
dealing with racism was like it was not
real and I was making up and lying about
it because I look like a white person
and then my response was like you're
racist and you know you are that white
person that claims racism is happening
but then when someone tells you you
dismiss it and then you know we got
heated he stood up he smacked smacked
the mic all started yelling and then uh
and then we apologized we hugged it out
we hung out for a little bit after the
show and chilled on the couch and we
talked and you know I told him to come
back whenever you want it was a good
conversation these things happen but
people love drama yeah they do so
expensive microphones as well yeah it's
fine it just spun around yeah but that's
what got me is if you come in here and
start damaging property that's about
that's beyond personal but but the
virality of the clip shows exactly why
these people make content about us in
that way because they're like oh this
will you know people love e-drama yeah
it's like well you know I'm not going to
do that you would watch that okay
imagine um you just a clip comes out and
Tom Cruise has just punched Brad Pitt in
the face you've watched that right yeah
it's like if a story came out I mean
look that's why all these crime videos
go viral because people are like they
want to see the crisis and the conflict
not not everybody some people are
genuinely concerned that crime is
escalating in their cities that I get
but there's a lot of people you know I
there was this young guy once
this is a couple years ago and I had
like 200 000 subscribers and he started
making nothing but Tim pool videos he
would watch a video and then he would
make a video about me and then I dm'd
him on Twitter and I just said bro
I am not famous enough for you to
succeed making content About You can
disagree with me you can insult me but
if you want to make it on YouTube talk
about the big picture news stories that
that people are interested in
most people in this country know who Joe
Biden is they're concerned about his
leadership that's important to the
average person I'm some dude on YouTube
no one's ever heard of and then the dude
stopped doing it and started making
different videos it's like the drama
stuff is not you know what it is it's an
addiction and it ends up destroying
people before they get started because
you build a channel based off of Rage
bait hatred for a single individual the
market cap on that is microscopic so you
build up a channel based on that then as
soon as you try to segue into talking
about big picture news nobody watches
then YouTube destroys your channel
saying your fans don't like your content
it's also a human instinct to pay
attention to people fighting because it
could be a threat to your life
historically speaking and big Tech
social media has been prioritizing it
putting it front face in the algorithm
and promoting such behavior and and
creating more Insanity yeah that's why
we like True Crime sort of yes exactly
practice you're sort of practicing
whenever you particularly women love
True Crime oh yeah I was that true crime
Con in in the UK it was it was just like
99 yeah it's like 99 women it was all
women they're just loving the True Crime
because they're the ones who are often
the victims of it and I have to sort of
watch it all right pinochet's helicopter
tours says when you tear out a Man's
Tongue you are not proving him a liar
you're only telling the world that you
fear what he might say George R.R Martin
yup yeah and then it says acock is that
was that the book
I believe that's what they're
referencing I mean it was a Game of
Thrones show where we we heard that but
it was I believe a quote from the book
that George RR Martin wrote it's a good
one man
it is a good one
should we guess what that what that was
what was it a [ __ ] AC okay it's the name
of the book I think which we get it must
be like a you want to look it up a [ __ ]
of Kings
how do you spell [ __ ]
a-c-o-k Game of Thrones or like George R
Martin AC okay A Clash of Kings there
you go wait that's a mount that's a mod
for Mountain blade also I think it's the
Game of Thrones Clash of Kings highly
recommend Mountain blade if you haven't
played it yet t-dub says how does
allowing illegal immigrants help
Democrats with voting if illegals can't
vote is it a generational thing t-dub
good sir I have the answer for you you
see
the census counts all people not
citizens so if a state has a large
number of illegal immigrants the census
will count them congressional seats are
then a portion based on the total number
of people not total number of citizens
this means that a state like California
will get an extra electoral vote it will
get an extra vote in Congress based on
their population of illegal immigrants
they don't need to actually vote but the
state will get an extra vote for the
president when the presidential election
happens and that's how it happens and I
think California previously had one
extra congressional seat and one extra
electoral vote based on their illegal
immigration population it's gone down
recently maybe something to do with
Trump I don't know but uh that is a
major concern and then also I think
studies show that the children of
illegal immigrants overwhelmingly vote
Democrat the first time they do vote I
don't know if that's true or not but I
know that the census thing matters
that's why Donald Trump wanted the
census question I'm sorry the
citizenship question on the census that
surprises me because there is that
instinct I think to like go get to a
country and shut the door behind you you
know that you know the thing of like
okay
TW says get sticks on here I want to
hear Tim Luke Ian and Styx discuss
monetary systems that'd be cool he
doesn't believe gold-backed currency is
better hopefully episodes 666 he said
he's down to make an appearance
um how about we calculate when episode
666 will be and sticks that's when we
get you on because that would be
fantastic yeah that sounds like a great
idea we were supposed to meet up with
him in in Upstate New York once and then
plans fell through
stick Saxon hammer on episode 666 and
right now we're on like episode 636 or
something like that so we're close let's
make it happen yeah so in one month
in one month we got it we gotta gotta
happen episode 666 would be the best
time to have them on that'd be great
it's it's turned out I don't know I
don't know how far booked out we are but
I'd like to say we can Reverb Reserve
666 just for sticks yeah I mean I think
we could do that
that would be great we gotta bring
Sheamus back to like uh uh spread holy
water around the show before episode 777
for sure for 666 I mean big man evil
says PayPal spelled backwards is lap Yap
and that sounds like a company that
would do what Daddy government says
I agree jdoc says 65 of ethereum is
owned by five entities I'd like to see
some reference and documentation on that
but I'm not I wouldn't be surprised if
it turned out
all right
Let's uh Donald Thomas says hey Ian
before you question somebody about
banking Hitler do research when people
have that power they're the ones that
control the currency and Hitler was in
the in the process of creating a German
currency
wow well they had the guns you know
yeah okay I didn't quite understand that
do research on what exactly on on the
history of it basically saying that
Hitler was trying to control the
currency so how would you debank him you
know what I mean if he's right if he's
if he's if if the person's in charge of
Federal Reserve yeah I think a lot of I
don't know but I've heard that Hitler's
anger was about he blamed Jewish people
but a lot of it was the banking industry
on Earth and uh historically it was kind
of pioneered by amshel Rothschild who
was an Ashkenazi Jew and so the Jewish
thing got a bad reputation but it was
actually the Rothschild family that had
kind of co-opted the banking industry
this is the problem with like a lot of
anti-semites because I've like talked to
people these rallies and they'll say
like something about the Jewish people
and I'm like no you're criticizing a
person in power who happens to be Jewish
it's like I know a bunch of poor Jewish
people like it's just you're just
looking at someone choosing the one
trait you think determines and and the
annoying thing about it is a lot of it
is basically Jewish privilege they're
like oh these Jewish people you know
they hire each each other and they do
this and I'm like you're just describing
White Privilege but you're saying Jew
instead like it's just stupid come on
man it is frustrating and I I always
want it's actually really alluring that
conspiracy of all conspiracies it's like
I I want to believe it and and being
Jewish myself I always felt like oh God
you know it would be typical if that was
true and I was just somehow left out I
was the one the one Jew they never
called and like everyone's in on it but
you yeah well when you know I was
telling you before the show about you
know I couldn't get a job uh after my
first couple of documentaries they kept
saying you can't be on screen anymore
and uh I remember thinking then like
where's this supposed like Jewish people
that I can call like where's my yeah my
line to Ben Stiller and say like hey
this is still like why can't I get this
but but a better example in New York
when the government started shutting
down synagogues and and chaining Parks
shut directly targeting Jewish schools
come on man you know oh and to clarify
you had said you were not getting put on
camera after your first two because they
wanted people of color was that that was
they specified they said we need people
of color
the term they use in the UK although
they're moving away from it they always
there's always a new term and then it
becomes offensive and there's another
what is it aaip or something
no no but the new one they're doing here
is aapi it's uh what is it Asian
American Pacific Islander it's like uh
it's a way to catch people out I think
like for a long time it was you know uh
black people was what you were no it was
obviously it was colored was before
wasn't it and then for like 30 years
after you weren't supposed to say
colored anymore in the UK there was
still some like older people who were
maybe less educated who still used it
and they would be vilified and it was
fun it was fun for everyone to go you're
you you're not educated and you don't
know the right word it finally got to
the point about two years ago that
everyone in the UK for example knew
you're not supposed to you like every
single person like grandparents you're
not supposed to say and then they
changed they changed it again to people
of color yeah right right it was finally
right at that moment and they tried to
confuse them again it's a way of just
going you guys are uneducated and yes
you don't know the latest things but
yeah
black African minority ethnic wow and
Jews are not included in in that usually
um and that's who they wanted to replace
me with they would take my ideas for
different documentaries and stuff but uh
providing I'd be off screen so that they
have a minority that's illegal in the
United States it's probably probably in
the UK as well oh then sue yeah I can't
prove it
oh you know I mean in the United States
you don't need to that's the problem
like you just make the accusation and
that's it Court of public opinion I've
had people call up afterwards and say
like hi so sorry like we were taking
your idea and everything we were going
to use you but it occurred to us that um
you are a white man and we can't take
you anymore and I'm just like oh okay
well yeah yet again that's why I started
my podcast because I thought okay that's
the only way now I couldn't work I I had
no money no nothing I had to make the
podcast but I even found making the
podcast there's still there's so many
things that if you want to win Awards to
get to different levels and stuff it's
still you can't do it you've got to
you've got to have some ethnic thing
going on or you will not be considered
all right the Sinister sibling says to
challenge the previous superchat most of
us believe in God as a means of higher
power judging us allowing the main
reason for us to have moral restrain
lose that and you become the modern left
I think that the modern left is an
example of a lack of a moral framework
whereas one thing that unifies a lot of
people from post-liberal libertarian and
conservative the right Freedom faction
is Christian moral framework I am not
saying that you believe everything in
the Bible or you believe every teaching
or every law of it but there is a
tradition that was passed down rooted in
in traditional Christian morals we've
gotten rid of many of them our cultural
morals have shifted quite a bit but a
lot of them are still there the woke
people have no moral framework at all
that's why they constantly change the
definition of things that's why one
thing some like wimixin and women are
both offensive and both not offensive at
the same time in a superposition of both
in offense and offense because there is
no rule there is no framework it's just
to them might makes Right double thing
too well my next right so whatever it
means to give them power that's all they
care about I just had a thought that
maybe God isn't judgmental but that we
are judgmental of ourselves and so God
is this plaintive explanation uh and
then we are taking that and based on our
sociological framework judging our own
behavior and then we say that God's
judging us because we're feeling it but
we're the ones that are putting the
feelings on top of it I feel like the
Christian view of things is that God is
basically running a sorting algorithm
you get all of these people who are born
and sold onto this planet and they live
a life so that they're sorted into the
bad place and the good place and then
you know from a logical perspective in
that capacity I wonder I I if it was
taken out of the context of religion and
you had let's say a human with a chicken
farm
and the chickens were allowed to do
whatever they want and then what happens
is at the end of the year or the end of
the chicken's life
or I should say at the end of the year
chickens are reaching their their
reproduction age about seven months you
sort them the ones that were bad get
shuffled off in the meat grinder and the
ones that were good Go off into the
paradise of reproduction there's a
purpose for the Sorting algorithm at
capacity so when I hear these these
these you know these religious views I
think of it logically like
if there is a God and there are rules to
this it's not arbitrary it's not simply
that you're here just to live a good
life so that you can prove it and then
go be with God it's that you're supposed
to live a good life for a reason because
the good people that move on move on for
something greater and more important
than just this sorting algorithm the
least important thing is figuring out
which chicken to breed the most
important thing is successfully breeding
the good chicken so if I had a bunch of
chickens and I was taking the bad ones
and eating them and having the good ones
reproduce over a long enough period of
time you're getting better and better
and better chickens the greater purpose
is beyond that one day or that seven
months they spend in the pen
so for those of us here on Earth if you
believe there is judgment and greater
power there is a greater purpose for
your existence that lies Beyond this
life
and if you're bad into the meat grinder
yeah well it'll be into the AI uh
algorithm where you just become
self-sterilized and are in like a doped
State while you eventually die off and
the rest of the people that are aware
and awake are reproducing to create
space travel here's here's a crazy
thought that someone else probably
already had
what if the reason these Ultra wealth
Elites are desperately trying to become
immortal is that they know they're
headed for the bad place wow so it's uh
in the World of Warcraft expansion
shadowlands
I don't know it's been a while since I
was reading about it because like I
didn't actually play it I played it a
little bit but it's basically Sylvanas
and I'm way behind in the story for all
the warcraft fans but Sylvanas was like
uh
she she was um what you call it the the
Lich King turned her resurrected her and
so she was condemned to in the afterlife
this really horrifying torturous place
so then she was like screw that I refuse
to go there through no fault so she
shatters the veil between the this realm
and the shadow shadowlands or whatever
so I'm thinking about all these Ultra
rich people and they're like these evil
nasty corporate Global Elite or whatever
and they'll they all strive towards
immortality not all of them but a lot of
them there are a lot of them who are
working towards this stuff and they're
thinking like when I die I'm going down
so I better just live forever and never
leave this place that's a new one but
Heaven and Hell or on Earth guys
is it a new one I feel like someone's
probably thought of that before I'd live
forever I'd love to live forever yeah
this is this is great okay okay Jared
Kushner
I just like like breathing's great oh
it's not good you know what's great yeah
eating Chick-fil-A yeah well I don't
know what that is but yeah well it's
chicken chicken sandwiches all right so
great you know you know it's also really
great
chicken fajitas from a nice Mexican
restaurant yeah super good yeah green
peppers onions chicken oh guacamole sour
cream rice and beans stop making me
hungry
sometimes I'll have the star where I'm
like I don't want to live again if I if
I have to come back and relive this life
of Ian right now is great but my
childhood was not it was like what hell
like taking so long but then I'm like if
I beg not to do this again will I not
wake up tomorrow like am I actually
begging for the end of the simulation so
like keep going you know come back if
you got to come back you know what's an
interesting perspective um uh a
potential thing that could happen
because I've interviewed a few people
about like living forever and there are
quite a lot of people now transhumanists
they're called who who believe we can
live forever Just by changing the
biology and whatever and some people say
that can happen in our lifetimes and
some don't right some say the first
person the first person to live forever
has already been born and you know uh
but what someone mentioned to me the
other day was that if that's not
possible if we if virtual reality gets
good enough you might be able to slow
down our own lived experience of life to
such an extent that that it would feel
like living forever like you could be in
virtual reality and live millions and
millions of experience time but in our
real
existence it would only be like 10
seconds wow yeah and the opposite could
be true where uh 10 years go by and you
have like a 10 second experience right
that's yeah that's like prism I'd have
lost 10 years yeah I guess you'd want
you'd want to get get through prison
that'd be horrible for that we need
these algorithms open source because
machines can bend and warp time
perceptually for you perception is
everything now too man well if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel and be the notification you want
to see from YouTube they're not
notifying people of the live stream and
the videos so just share them if you
want to support us so that we can bypass
the censorship head over to timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up at about 11 pm
you don't want to miss it they're good
fun and as a member you're supporting
our journalists and helping us in this
Mission we are we had a meeting today
about producing some music we were
planning on putting out something out in
a couple a couple weeks ago but we
decided to make sure we did everything
to the best of our abilities so we are
it's looking like we're gonna have a
song a political song released just
before the Friday before the election I
think is a strategy great and the lyrics
are overtly political and so we were
like no no let's let's lean into it and
then uh so we Shuffle some things around
and I think the the idea here idea there
is that no one is waiting for your song
that's what the marketing guy said like
music comes out and then people will
like it and listen to it but no one is
sitting there screaming begging you to
release it now so do it when it makes
sense and I said okay so with your
support we're going to do more to
challenge the culture and expand so uh
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me at timcast Andrew do
you want to shut anything out yeah um
thank you all for having me so much I've
had a lovely time come to on the edge
with Andrew gold uh YouTube or audio
podcast in all the normal places I've
Speak to lots of weird and interesting
fun people all right bloody bloke thank
you so much for coming on my website is
Luke uncensored.com I'm really proud of
the last two videos I did on there if
you need some uplifting if you're
feeling knackered or miffed you should
definitely check out the two videos I
did on Luke uncensored.com they are
proper I'm just taking the piss here
Cheerio thanks Luke and adios to you as
well my friend uh Hey guys if you want
to check out more esoteric weirdness uh
follow me anywhere and also check out my
podcast my show with uh hotep Jesus
today where we talked a little bit about
God Jesus and plan to do much more in
that realm sorry it was pronounced all
right I always I love hearing how you
guys do the uh accents Tim's pretty good
I've been Amazed by his Impressions so
far oh hey thank you Alex Jones so one
thing I wish I could do the only one I
could do is like Jordan Peterson which I
don't think I should do give me some JP
yeah wow
um well well you well you know you know
it's bloody you're a chimpanzee full of
snakes you gotta make your bed man
psychologist
there you go hey guys I'll still be
around next episode and the one after
that and for the next few in the future
so cheers see you around you can follow
me at surge.com just spill it out and uh
I'll see you guys next time again thanks
for hanging out everybody we will see
you all over at timcast.com cheers guys